durci le ton envers benyamin netanyahu
appelant à une désescalade est
aujourd'hui dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien déclarations après
qu'israël a dit attendre le moment
opportun pour cesser ses frappes sur
gaza ville ont à dissuader le hamas de
lancer de nouvelles roquettes sur le
terrain dans le sublimant notamment les
tirs israéliens se poursuivent en
riposte au lancement de roquettes
nous serons avec notre correspondante
pour l'asca hier en direct de tel aviv
le sommet de l'arctique a débuté
aujourd'hui en islande russie et états
unis vont confronter leurs ambitions
dans la zone et les profs avaient
annoncé en aimant que la zone arctique
était celle de la russie et qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à la défendre et après
le retrait des états unis l'année
dernière du traité surveillants ciel
ouvert c'est au tour de la russie de se
retirer après le vote des députés
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
plus de trente cinq mille policiers mais
aussi le ministre de l'intérieur et des
politiques de tous bords une
manifestation pas comme les autres a
donc eu lieu cet après midi devant
l'assemblée nationale à paris à l'appel
des syndicats des forces de l'ordre et
ce deux semaines après le meurtre du
brigadier éric masson avignon l approche
d'importantes élections électorales
on retrouve tout de suite katia pique
nique devant le palais bourbon
bonsoir katia malgré le vent et la pluie
35000 personnes -policiers soutien
syndicats et politiques de tous bords
ont convergé devant l'assemblée
nationale sur le quai d'orsay
les policiers réclament davantage de
moyens humains et financiers une
meilleure protection
une simplification de la procédure
pénale et des peines plancher en
tribunes ils ont dénoncé le police
bashing l'impunité grandissante la
spirale de la violence
ils ont également rendu hommage au
policier décédé on écoute des
responsables syndicalistes
ce qu'on constate qu'il ya beaucoup de
forces de sécurité intérieure de
policiers mais aussi de citoyens qui
sont de nombreux soutenir leurs polices
et sator un peu le cou à la thèse
qu'accréditent le fait que la population
ne nous soutient pas et bien c'est tout
la verse pour voir d'où sortent pour
l'instant très satisfait et si nous
sommes rassemblés ici c'est surtout pour
nous deux pour dénoncer les conditions
de travail insupportables dans les clous
travaillons et surtout via les violences
des violences dont nous sommes les
cibles quotidiennement c'est pour ça que
nous nous voulons des actes il ya tous
les élus qui sont là qui se font une
tribune politique qui sont venus moi je
demande à tous ses élus ruda de leurs
clivages politiques d'aller dans l'autre
sens pour faire en sorte que les
réponses pénales soit très ferme
immédiate lorsque les policiers sont
attaqués on verra pour la suite du
mouvement en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que ça peut durer très longtemps
et on lâchera pas et on continuera
en effet le premier ministre nous a
reçus il nous a reçus nous a pas annoncé
grand chose en tout cas rien de
suffisant pour nous tant qu'il n'y aura
pas ces peines minimales
qu'on arrête de nous trouver des excuses
sur la constitution et autres si c'est
anticonstitutionnel warrants voyons la
constitution s'il faut légiférer y avait
beaucoup d'élus c'est leur rôle de
travailler à l'assemblée pour faire en
sorte que les policiers soient
respectées et considérées
mais une bonne fois pour toutes
pensons aux collègues sur le terrain
quitte climat longueur de temps qui sont
régulièrement blessé qui sont tués pense
aux familles des victimes et pensons
aussi aux citoyens ils étaient là
aujourd'hui le citoyen en a marre de ces
nuisances et incivilités cette violence
et dangerosité
tout le monde en a marre donc le
gouvernement doit prendre conscience de
la situation parce que nous on va
continuer on va pas lâcher des élus de
tous bords étaient venus nombreux mais
ils n'ont bien sûr pas eu le droit de
s'exprimer à la tribune des
syndicalistes on écoute olivier faure
pour le ps et jordan bardella pour le rn
moi je suis venu engager un dialogue
avec eux sur les meilleures réponses à
apporter aux problèmes qu'ils posent le
problème qu'il pose c'est effectivement
des gens qui sont insuffisamment
condamner des gens qui sont parfois
relâchés sans avoir eu à subir la
moindre sanction est donc comment est-ce
qu'on répond à ces événements à ces
faits qui ont été rappelées cet
après-midi et qu'elle s'attende à
travers sa tante d'exemple nous avons
commencé à dialoguer avec eux lundi
dernier lors d'une intersyndicale avec
laquelle nous avons dialogué
nous allons continuer semaine après
semaine pour chercher à apporter les
solutions qui permettront à chacune et à
chacun d'aller vers ce but commun qui
est la protection des français
moi j'ai entendu les syndicats a appellé
l'intégralité des formations politiques
et des citoyens à venir se joindre à eux
c'est ce que nous faisons à la fois pour
leur témoigner la reconnaissance de la
nation est évidemment celle du
rassemblement national ou qu'est-ce qui
parmi leurs revendications que vous
voyez reprendre vous dans votre
beaucoup le rétablissement des peines
planchers le mandat de dépôt
systématique lorsque vous touchez
aujourd'hui à un policier qui est une
exception ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
forces de l'ordre ce qu'elles sont
agressés recroise bien souvent leur
agresseur dans les semaines qui suivent
la volonté de les protéger aujourd'hui
par le droit en instaurant une
présomption de légitime défense
beaucoup de mesures que nous avons
longtemps porté dans le débat public et
qui sont aujourd'hui portés c'est vrai
par les forces de l'ordre et que nous
mettrons en oeuvre à la tête de l'état
la polémique c'est bien sûr la venue du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
qui est aussi le premier flic de france
en tribune on a pu entendre le problème
de la police et la justice
le nom du garde des sceaux eric dupond
moretti s'est fait huer certaines
organisations de policiers dénonce une
récupération politique
mais maintenant ils attendent des actes
très cette manifestation peut-elle faire
changer les choses les critiques des
policiers concernant notamment la
justice on les a beaucoup entendu
aujourd'hui sont elles justifiées
enfin la présence des politiques
n'étaient elles pas qu'un coup de com
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage et
face à face ce soir
pour en parler nous sommes avec david
guiraud porte-parole jeunesse la france
insoumise bonsoir david guiraud merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés virginie
joron députée européenne rassemblement
national bonsoir à vous madame merci
d'être avec nous également
au moins 35 mille un manifestant
aujourd'hui des policiers des élus on en
reparlera évidemment mais tout d'abord
première question en virginie jauron
pour vous il y aura un avant et un après
ce que c'est une manifestation pour rien
ou enfin le message va être entendu
selon vous déjà il n'y a pas un avant et
un après ça fait des années qu'elle ce
malaise aujourd'hui une prise de
conscience de tous puisque effectivement
il avait plus de trente cinq mille
manifestants il y avait une
intersyndicale dont plusieurs syndicats
pour exprimer le même mot d'ordre donc
le malaise policier
effectivement le besoin de se faire
entendre parce qu'on le voit depuis des
mois et surtout que ces dernières
semaines un emballement delà de la
violence envers les forces de l'ordre
qui est insupportable et évidemment nous
étions présents parce que c'est aussi un
devoir citoyen de rendre hommage à cette
profession qui est de plus en plus mal
traités
nous avons pas attendu effectivement ce
jour pour toujours soutenir cette
profession nous allons déjà l'an passé
proposé un plan pour complet de
propositions quarantaine de propositions
pour effectivement mettre en avant les
policiers leur donner plus de moyens
matériels de la formation plus de moyens
en matière pénale aussi puisque
effectivement le problème c'est qu'il ya
un sentiment d'impunité mais il ya même
plus de sentiments il ya une impunité
totale et donc effectivement nous sommes
là avec eux depuis le début et demain
encore plus on a vu évidemment beaucoup
de politiques sur ce cortège
l'un d'entre eux a brillé par son
absence la france insoumise votre parti
david guiraud virginie jour on nous
parlait d'un devoir citoyen d'en être
aujourd'hui pourquoi vous vous avez
refusé d'être présent sur place la
france a soumis ce qu à écouter c'est
simple on nous avait parlé à la base
d'un hommage en général un hommage pour
des morts vous venez avec des fleurs
un catalogue de revendications ensuite
on nous a dit que c'était une
manifestation citoyenne j'ai pas vu de
citoyens d'ailleurs les étés y avait que
des policiers des journalistes qui
étaient autorisés à entrer dans ce
rassemblement bon et ensuite j'ai
entendu les revendications des
organisations policières et ses
organisations policières nous disent
quoi c'est la faute de la justice que il
n'y a pas assez de fermeté qui est du
laxisme judiciaire
tout ça s'appuie sur e1 je pense à un
désarroi réel des policiers c'est vrai
qu'il ya une souffrance c'est vrai qu'il
ya des moyens qui sont en berne
mais par contre je peux pas laisser dire
des choses fausses parce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont fausses
quand on dit qu un laxisme judiciaire
vous êtes quand même au courant que les
violences sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique le taux de réponse
pénale c'est 95%
quand vous faites des violences sur des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
vous avez 75% de condamnations qui sont
assorties d'une peine de prison
même quand il nya pas du tt
d'interruption de travail donc pardon
mais il est où le laxisme là dedans le
taux de réponse pénale en 2016 ces 94 8
7% en 2008 18 aussi 2010 9 95%
c'est quoi ces du laxisme ça le
ministère de la justice lui même
il dit que les violences sur les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique elles sont plus souvent l'objet
de deux procédures à l'éternel sont
elles font moins souvent l'objet de
procédures alternatives que les autres
peine 20% d'un côté contre 40 % dans les
autres domaines
il ya de la comparution immédiate dont
on sait que la comparution immédiate
vous même bien plus souvent sur des
sanctions judiciaires lourde à 22 %
quand il s'agit de deux délits sur les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique compte 9 % pour les autres il
est où le laxisme
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on m'ait qu'on me
le dise je veux bien avoir une
discussion mais sur des faits concrets
parce que là aujourd'hui il ya une
souffrance de tous les agents de l'état
ap les policiers d'ailleurs qui souffre
de manque d'effectifs jeu bien en parler
mais aussi de leurs missions qu'on leur
donne et moi je peux pas accepter qu'on
commence à discuter sur des suppositions
basé sur aucun argument concret juste en
instrumentalisant une souffrance ça
c'est pas honnête on va les passer
david journal on va aller dans le monde
du débat dans quelques instants mais
mais
mais avant tout sur la présence
politique parce que c'était quand même
l'un des débats qui a émaillé ce
rassemblement entre la présence de
gérald darmanin et votre absence à vous
la france est soumise
votre collègue jean zen bardella très
critique envers d'ailleurs elle est
fille qui nous a expliqué que selon le
numéro deux du rnd roncq un jean luc
mélenchon représente une partie de la
gauche qui a sombré dans du jusqu'au
boutisme séparatiste virginie joron vous
partager cette opinion
oui c'est vraiment les absents mais en
même temps ça m'étonne pas puisque ils
ont un discours anti flics depuis le
début alors c'est facile d'annoncer des
chiffres mais en même temps ce qui
prouve une chose c'est que peut-être
vous annoncer les chiffres qu'il n'y a
pas de laxisme judiciaire
mais en attendant en moins d'une semaine
vous avez tous les jours des faits
divers qui prouve que ya un emballement
de la violence donc ce qui veut dire que
la réponse pénale n'est pas adapté donc
il ya déjà la réalité en prenant juste
une semaine de faits divers
vous n'avez qu'à regarder la semaine du
27 avril vous avez tous les jours des
attaques contre les forces de l'anp un
emballement de long le voyais à plus de
6000 policiers blessés en une année ça a
doublé donc voilà il a dû il ya du
factuel vous voulez l'ignorer et à côté
de ça vous voulez pas certes il allait
faire corps avec cette force de l'ars
qui sont là pour nous protéger
ça c'est quelque chose que vous vous
laisse entendre sans doute pas entendre
mais sont là pour protéger la nous
protéger tout citoyen quelles que soient
nos couleurs politiques et aussi
restaurer la paix et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un dans un chaos on le voit
tous les jours avec ces faits divers ils
sont là pour protéger et surtout
rétablir la paix sociale la paix partout
dans les banlieues partout dans les
villes et c'est un constat qui est qui
est effrayant et cette manifestation
elle est là pour dire attention
attention il faut prendre tu te les élus
tous les élus doivent abandonner pour
prendre conscience parce que c'est de
pire en pire et si aujourd'hui on
continue à se voiler la face
demain ça va être la guerre civile david
guiraud c'est vrai que la geste et ça
c'était d'ailleurs l'un de vos griefs
envers cette manifestation la justice a
été prise pour cible les dégâts d'un
cran n'ont plus de limites
le problème de la justice de la police
et la justice c'est vrai qu'on entendait
des témoignages nous dire où là on a à
peine fini de rédiger le pv que les
délais de caen sont déjà dehors est ce
que ça c'est une réalité
ça semble être le cas en tout cas sur le
terrain que vous m'aimiez à la france un
son mythe
non mais attendez sur le taux sur le
délai de réponse pénale ya un problème
parce que la justice manque de moyens
c'est pas de la faute des magistrats
c'est que l'état a désinvesti la justice
mais j'aimerais revenir sur ce que
disait madame jour où madame judy
attention demain ça va être la guerre
civile ça vous dérange pas la guerre
civile madame 1 qu'en 2019 êtes allé à
damas en syrie en twittant qu'à damas y
faisait bon vivre avec le pays avec la
capitale sont au sein d'une guerre
civile soit pas l'air de trop vous
déranger ans ça a l'air d'aller
vous nous dites des chiffres regarder
typiquement la désinformation à laquelle
vous participez vous nous dites ya 6000
agression de policiers
d'accord vous êtes au courant parmi les
6000 agression de policiers madame 70%
ces des accidents s'étaient fait
accidentel c'est pas des agressions donc
pardon mais moi je veux bien reconnaître
payer des agressions sur les possibles
vous savez je vais même vous dire qu'il
ya une légère augmentation effectivement
des agressions sur les policiers dans le
pays il ya une spécificité tristement
française c'est que les attentats
terroristes visent souvent plus les
policiers en ce moment que les civils ça
c'est une réalité dont il faut parler il
ya du trafic de drogue et du trafic de
drogue qui en expansion dans le pays
s'est adressé une réalité
mais vous savez la france soumise après
des propositions là dessus la france me
demande juste à ce qu'on voit les choses
autrement qu uniquement par le biais
sécuritaire parce que le biais
sécuritaires ces poids sur le trafic de
drogue c'est un million d'heures qu'on a
donnée de travail à la police en plus
bon quels sont les résultats
les gens consomment plus de cannabis
qu'avant ces 150 mille interpellations
par an à part mettre des policiers dans
l'embarras est ce que ça résout le
problème du trafic de drogue venant donc
on dit juste on veut changer la
politique et arrêter d'être dans le
délire sécuritaire pour une raison
simple c'est que tu ne profites pas la
population mais surtout quand vous
pensez régler tous les problèmes de la
société uniquement les mettant sur
d'au-delà policiers des policiers eh ben
vous mettez les policiers en danger dans
l'embarras pourquoi parce que les
policiers vont être investis de missions
qu'ils n'ont pas
1 parce que les policiers sont pas
médecins ne sont pas prof ils sont pas
assistants sociaux ils sont pas
psychologue et que vu que l'état reculé
dans tous ces domaines c'est eux souvent
qui se retrouve à être appelés pour des
tâches parfois absurde parce que des
fois y'a pas de paul il n'y a pas de
médecins qui viennent dans les quartiers
alors on appelle des policiers parce que
des fois il ya des des choses qui
pourraient être réglés par des
médiateurs
on appelle les policiers et vous voyez
le problème de la dérive sécuritaire il
est là il est dans le fait que des gens
pensent tout réglé avec la police bah
moi je le dis je l'affirmé je n'ai pas
peur de le dire ça marchera pas il n'y a
aucun pays où ça marche est typiquement
si on n'est pas allé à un rassemblement
aujourd'hui mais c'est pour une raison
simple c'est qu'on partage pas les
revendications les peines plancher on a
connu ça on a l'expérience en france des
peines planchers faudrait peut-être
quand même un jour faire le bilan de ce
qu'on a fait c'était la loi dati la loi
dati on a l'expérience de ce qui s'est
passé
de 2007 à 2010 devinez quoi
les taux de récidive des gens qui ont
été jugés avec les peines plancher ils
ont augmenté
donc en fait la répression pas ça marche
pas à tous les cas voilà et donc ceux
qui disent ça sont taxée d'anti fiq pas
d'accord mais moi en attendant ce que je
constate c'est depuis que je suis gamin
j'entends toujours le même discours et
que la situation fait que s'aggraver
donc je le dis que ce soit aux arènes
qui est cohérent dans sa logique le rnd
cohérent darmanin je comprends un peu
moins le ps comprend - le parti
communiste français je comprends moi ça
j'avoue j'ai un peu honte même que des
gens se soit fourvoyé là dedans mais je
le dis juste qu'il ya un débat de
société
est-ce que sécuritaire ça marche au-delà
des questions idéologiques et quand vous
regardez les chiffres la sécurité à las
casas marche
écoutez - déjà quand j'entends ça je me
dis on vit pas sur un même planète
monsieur parce que vous gêne vous avez
donc à une autre vision moi j'aime ma
gêne je voulais rentrer dans la police
veut faire des ss police sécurité c'est
en 96 et j'ai fait un mois dans un
commissariat et j'ai vu déjà le métier
le malaise et les difficultés qu'ils
avaient déjà à exercer leur métier et
vous vous niez donc en fait pour vous le
problème c'est que c'est donc les
dealers donc si les pâtes d'inertie et
pas de drogue aurait pas donc de devoir
livrer pas qu'il y aurait pas vivre dans
un monde
merveilleux parce que effectivement le
problème donc si on a instauré la
répression de la droite et hot
finalement délit donc en fait pour vous
il faut pas de délit il faut pas de
policier et on est dans un monde de
bisounours mais pardon mais ce n'est pas
la réalité
bassil c'est un peu ce que nous dit en
fait il faut dépénaliser il faut
dépénaliser pour pas donc mais des
forces de l'ordre dans dance est dans
cette perspective d'arrêter des dealers
et du coup finalement on vit vraiment
charmant de merde des lieux mais non moi
je suis désolé et aussi et la population
aujourd'hui vie cette insécurité je suis
désolé peut-être vous vous ne vivez pas
et tant mieux pour vous mais là la
majorité des français sont cent se
sentent agressés quelques dents tout
dans tout les mêmes ruralité paris est
évidemment dans certains quartiers plus
que d'autres mais même dans la ruralité
donc voilà je pense qu'on vit pas sur la
même planète tant mieux pour vous à part
un tout se passe bien chez vous mais je
pense que c'est pas la majorité des
français qui vivent la même chose que
oui bah alors madame pardon excusez moi
puisque c'est à bruxelles et ses abords
de cette mine aux gets que la
seine-saint-denis
pardon mais juste moi je veux vous dire
une chose le baiia pas non plus pas que
trafic de drogue j'ai pas dit ça je sais
pas quelle position vous n'affrontez je
vous dis juste que par contre on veut
changer radicalement les politiques
publiques en termes d' approche de la
criminalité et que moi je n'ai pas de
problème à parler de 2,2 éradication de
la délinquance c'est pas un problème et
ça passe pas que par le trafic de drogue
mais par contre ils sont quand même
prendre en compte cette dimension là
parce qu'il ya le trafic d armes
derrière quand on parle de police de
proximité quand on parle de renfort de
deux contrôles des douanes par exemple
de douaniers laisse tout passer avec
l'union européenne
c'est pas normal je suis désolé voilà
mais on est pour des approches concrètes
et quand on parle de sécurité je vous
dis juste que je ne veux pas ce délire
sécuritaire parce qu'ils en sont
conscientes a listé souffrance réelle
mais dans ce cas là parlons des
souffrances qu'elle policiers par
exemple qui sont liées ont donc demandé
au manque d'équipement
ça c'est des problèmes concrets si des
policiers manifestent au dessus il ya
pas mal alors juste devant à ce sujet là
le gouvernement il répond typiquement à
ces questions de demande de moyens je
vous propose d'écouter le porte parole
du gouvernement gabriel
attal nous sommes du côté des forces de
l'ordre
quand beaucoup ne se paie que des
formules et des coups de menton
nous soutenons les forces de l'ordre en
mots mais aussi en actes nous sommes
présents en augmentant les salaires des
gardiens est dégradée 200 euros nets par
mois
en renforçant la formation des policiers
en payant des millions d'heures
supplémentaires en renouvelant la moitié
des véhicules et en rénovant en rénovant
les commissariats et brigades de
gendarmerie le gouvernement est il
présent on actes et pas seulement en
mots virginie joron comme l'affirment
gabriela talent et comme vous voulez
l'attesté la présence de gérald darmanin
sur le terrain aujourd'hui encore une
fois c'est bien mais pourquoi maintenant
ça fait des années que nous sommes dans
cette situation ça fait des années et
des années que les forces de l'ordre
réclame des moyens
pourquoi attendre maintenant à quelques
mois des échéances électorales donc
c'est pour moi de la communication
j'espère effectivement que des moyens
vont être déployés mais encore une fois
il faut être cohérente c'est tout c'est
tout un plan qu'il faut mettre en place
mais en tout 40 propositions
effectivement de la formation des moyens
matériels un suivi d une cellule
spécifique aussi parce qu'il ya un taux
de 2 recrudescence de du suicide qui est
inacceptable
et évidemment un problème au niveau
pénal où il ya quand même malgré les
chiffres de monsieur guiraud il y a
quand même on le voit bien
un laxisme à ce niveau j'ai quelques
faits divers ou 1 où il ya eu une
attaque la semaine dernière à bagnolet
sur 20 personnes une seule personne a
été interpellée et c'est comme ça tous
les jours il est même cet après-midi
quand j'étais dans la manifestation j'ai
donc converser avec un policier il me
disait de toute façon les en un mot
d'ordre aujourd'hui ne plus intervenir
donc voilà on est dans cette situation
qui est gravissime
il y a un début de réponse mais elle est
trop tard et il faut un plan cohérent et
seul mou depuis des années nous sommes
nous avons nous avons réfléchi sur ce
sujet on a plus de 40 propositions en
matière de police on a une opposition
matière de justice donc on a un plan
cohérent et nous sommes prêts à soutenir
cette procession et surtout leur donner
les moyens dont ils ont besoin david
guiraud est un bon début mai mais c'est
trop tard
virginie joron sur l'action du
gouvernement votre avis et c'est le mot
de la fin rapidement s'il vous plaît non
rien ne va rénova moi je combats cette
logique sécuritaire qui d'ailleurs
effectivement créé des suicides c'est un
vrai sujet les suicides dans la police
plus d'ailleurs que les policiers qui
meurt en exercice en suicides dans la
police la france est soumise à proposer
une commission denquête à l'assemblée
pour savoir pourquoi les policiers
suicider qu'est ce qui se passait
comment résoudre le problème ça a été
refusé par aux marches et sur tous les
aspects de sécurité
on veut nous faire croire que augmenter
la répression ça marche mais déjà ces
gouvernements par exemple sur la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
qui était censée être la première cause
quand même du quinquennat à une des
grandes causes du quinquennat eh ben il
n'a pas été à la hauteur il n'a pas
débloqué les fonds suffisants sur la
justice moi je veux bien
les policiers disent que c'est de la
faute de la justice mais la justice elle
même demande à pouvoir bien faire son
métier
mais quand vous n'avez pas de greffier
dans les tribunaux pas de place pas de
créneaux horaires comment vous faites
vous pouvez pas et ça c'est des choses
concrètes
madame joron on se base sur des faits
divers va écouter si vous faites une
politique publique basée sur des faits
divers ont pour agen les amis moi je me
base sur les chiffres du ministère de la
justice sur les chiffres de
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales a
cédé voilà moi je ne sais pas il ya un
nombre pour être un peu sérieux en fait
dans ce qu'on fait pour être sérieuse et
discrète rester quel sacré sens de
chaque fois les statistiques 1 elles
sortent bien quelque part à la
statistique
et savez vous savez madame avec les
faits divers c'est tout le problème
moelleux y en a qui sont passés ce qui
alimente les statistiques
merci à 12h du carillon il a servi durée
en habits on allait là la fin oui les
filles super pardon il ya des morts tous
les jours tous les jours on pourrait les
les journaux télévisés pourrait se
transformer en rubrique nécrologique si
on le voulait est ce qu'on ferait
avancer c'est ça c'est dit chacun jugera
et on a démontré
merci merci david guiraud merci à
bergeron d'avoir été avec nous en direct
à 1 sur rt france le préfet de police de
paris a pris deux arrêtés d'interdiction
contre les manifestations pro
palestiniennes prévues ce week-end mais
aujourd'hui une manifestation était
autorisée à paris le collectif national
pour une paix juste et durable entre
palestiniens et israéliens appelés à se
regrouper place de la république ils
exigent de suite la fin de la politique
d'apartheid de l'état israélien la
protection du peuple palestinien et la
fin de l'impunité d'israël sur place on
retrouve notre reporter bassem chebi
bonsoir bassamat rassemblement donc lieu
pour soutenir les palestiniens et cette
fois on le rappelle le gouvernement et
le rassemblement était bizern autorisée
par la préfecture est ce qu'il y a du
monde
[Musique]
effectivement stéphanie c'était un
rassemblement autorisé par la préfecture
de police de paris un rassemblement qui
a commencé dans les alentours de 18
heures et qui vient de se terminer il ya
à peu près une vingtaine de minutes
ordre de dispersion c'était 20 heures
qu'on vous pouvez pas juste derrière moi
la place s'est vidé de ces manifestants
et de ces drapeaux palestiniens il était
beaucoup à être venus une centaine à
l'appel de plusieurs organisations et
partis politiques des associations
notamment comme à celle de france
palestine solidarité je suis avec son
président monsieur bertrand elle brode
merci de répondre aux questions des
références bonjour expliquez-nous dans
un premier temps le but de ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'abord de manifester notre solidarité
avec le peuple palestinien qui vit une
agression absolument terrible de la part
d'israël
c'est un déluge de bombes qui s'abat sur
gaza qui n'épargne aucune infrastructure
civile
aucune maison d'habitation les abords
des hôpitaux mais c'est aussi à
jérusalem d or de fascistes qui attaque
les habitants palestiniens de jérusalem
tous les jours en cisjordanie
ce sont des soulèvements pour protester
contre ce qui se passe à gaza et
jérusalem qui sont réprimées dans le
sang avec 13 morts vendredi dernier
aidé en israël même où la population
palestinienne d'israël se trouve
effectivement soumises à des attaques
racistes et des lynchages absolument
terrible
vous étiez plusieurs organisations
associations à avoir appelé à se
rassembler ici place de la république en
soutien après la manifestation de samedi
dernier qui avait été interdit ce
rassemblement autorisé et quel message
par rapport à ce rassemblement
souhaitiez vous passez avec vous les
autres associations gouvernement par
rapport à confier à cette crise qui lie
à entre israël et la palestine
alors c'est un message vis-à-vis du
gouvernement français de l'exécutif
d'une manière générale de colère nous
sommes très en colère de la manière dont
le ministère des affaires étrangères a
traité la question dans ses communiqués
en renvoyant dos à dos le presseur et le
primé
et nous sommes encore plus en colère de
la manière dont le président de la
république a osé dans un communiqué le
14 mai écrire la phrase terrible quand
lady luge de bombes s'abat sur gaza
israël a le droit de se défendre c'est
s'appelle un père me tuer
c'est ce qu'avait déjà fait hollande en
juillet 2014 c'est totalement
inadmissible et nous sommes très en
colère aussi contre lui
le ministre de l'intérieur darmanin qui
a insulté les militants de la solidarité
internationale et du droit international
que nous sommes pourrons nous en disant
qu'il s'agissait de manifestations
antisémites
c'est quelque chose qui est inadmissible
pour nous qu'il ya eu des manifestations
des rassemblements dans toute la france
le week-end dernier ils se sont toutes
déroulées sur le moindre discours de
haine même si l'émotion et la colère
sont très forts donc il faut vraiment
d'urgence qu'à tous les niveaux affaires
étrangères présidence intérieur le
gouvernement français l'exécutif
français révise sa position que vous
avez eu des réponses auprès de la
préfecture concernant la manifestation
de samedi prochain
sans négociation s'est fermement
interdit alors nous étions en
négociation tout à fait normal pour la
manifestation de samedi prochain qui
serait très manifestation très unitaire
très large avec une très forte
mobilisation des syndicats des partis
politiques et des associations comme la
nôtre nous étions en négociation tout à
fait normal ce soir nous avons eu
notification d'interdiction que nous
n'acceptons absolument pas
donc nous ne lâchons rien nous voulons
absolument manifester samedi prochain
dans un cadre organisé non interdites à
dire autorisé normal où les familles
puissent venir manifester leur
solidarité avec la palestine
je pense que ce n'est pas terminé nous
avons demain rendez-vous avec le préfet
de police et tenons nous comptons bien
avoir une autorisation pour manifester à
paris samedi à samedi prochain à 15h
comme nous l'avons pris merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir répondu à une question
avant lui compris les stéphanie un
rassemblement important pour ces
militants aujourd'hui après
l'interdiction de manifester un samedi
dernier ils sont bien décidés à
continuer de négocier avec la préfecture
de police de paris pour pouvoir
enfin organiser la manifestation de
samedi prochain en soutien aux
palestiniens si bassem chimie en direct
de la place de la république à paris
resté avec nous dans quelques instants
justement nous continuerons à parler de
ce conflit qui oppose israël au
territoire palestinien mais sur le
terrain cette fois nous irons retrouver
notre reporter sur place en israël et
puis nous irons en islande où se déroule
le sommet de l'arctique notre expert
décryptera la rencontre entre russie et
états unis
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après 20h30 soyez les bienvenus en
direct sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez alors que les réactions
internationales se multiplient les
bombardements entre israël et les
territoires palestiniens se poursuivent
le bilan s'alourdit jour après jour 217
palestiniens et 12 personnes côté
israélien ont perdu la vie depuis le
début du conflit il ya neuf jours l'état
hébreu dit étudier la possibilité d'un
cessez le feu mais les interventions de
bahia mines netanyahu et mahmoud abbas
aujourd'hui ne sont pas franchement
s'orienter dans cette direction voici le
récit de la journée avec florian lambert
[Musique]
un jour de plus dans l'escaladé
meurtrière entre israël et la palestine
au coeur d'une deuxième semaine de
conflit de nouveaux raids israéliens ont
frappé la bande de gaza ce mercredi un
peu plus tôt devant la presse un haut
responsable militaire de l'état hébreu a
indiqué que l'opportunité d'un cessez le
feu était actuellement à l'étude
un espoir rapidement nuancé par le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou qui n'entend pas revoir ses
positions et promet de venir à bout du
hamas si sa stratégie de dissuasion
n'aboutirait pas il n'y a que deux
façons d'y faire face
soit de les combattre et c'est toujours
une possibilité ouverte soit de les
dissuader et nous sommes actuellement
engagés dans la dissuasion mais je dois
dire que nous n'excluons rien nous
espérons pouvoir rétablir le calme nous
espérons pouvoir le faire rapidement
je tiens à dire que nous le faisons tout
en faisant de notre mieux pour éviter
les pertes civiles
nous n'avons pas cherché ce conflit en
plus de ces nouvelles menaces vers gaza
l'armée israélienne a annoncé ce
mercredi menaient des tirs d'artillerie
vers le sud du liban en représailles
pour le lancement de 4 roquettes depuis
le territoire libanais en direction de
l'état hébreu dans la bande de gaza le
peuple compte ses morts au milieu des
bâtiments détruits tandis que les
hommages aux civils tués sous les
bombardements se multiplient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des centaines de bâtiments ont été
détruits à gaza et plus de 70 mille
palestiniens ont été déplacés après les
frappes israéliennes dans un discours
télévisé le président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas dénonçant un
terrorisme d'état de la part d'israël
nous persisterons à demander des comptes
à ceux qui ont commis ces crimes devant
la cour pénale internationale
nos efforts se concentrent sur l'arrêt
de l'agression israélienne contre notre
peuple à jérusalem dans la bande de gaza
et en cisjordanie
nous entrerons alors dans un processus
politique sérieux avec un médiateur
international qui conduira la fin de
l'occupation israélienne des terres
palestiniennes y compris jérusalem est
notre capitale sacré de jérusalem
de son côté l'europe espère jouer son
rôle de médiateur
ce jeudi le chef de la diplomatie
allemande se rendre à jérusalem et
ramallah aux états unis joe biden vient
de hausser le ton pour inciter à un
cessez le feu
son soutien à israël ayant fortement
divisé l'opinion
plus que jamais le conflit
israélo-palestinien hystérise les
tensions au sein de la diplomatie
mondiale
et pour faire le point sur place nous
sommes en direct de tel aviv avec notre
correspondante paula slayer bonsoir hall
a ravi de vous retrouver qu'on est il de
la situation sur place après que les
etats-unis ont appelé à la désescalade
américain s'est entretenu par téléphone
avec benyamin nétanyahou aujourd'hui
disant qu'il souhaitait une désescalade
des violences aujourd'hui afin de mener
vers un cessez le feu
suite à cet entretien benyamin
nétanyahou a dit apprécier le soutien
pour israël fait de remarques direct sur
le contenu de cet entretien il a dit que
la mission continuerait et qu'israël
était déterminé à continuer cette
opération jusqu'au retour de la paix et
de la sécurité pour tous d'histoire
israélien tirs de roquettes israël
continue on était tous des rumeurs
aujourd'hui 250 roquettes et tirs de
mortiers on ne s'appartient touché
israël dans le sud et le centre du pays
hamas a menacé de viser aujourd'hui tel
à brive
il ya eu des incendies aujourd'hui
désastre et liens ont été dressés dans
le même temps là il sera éloigné mais un
communiqué oui fait rater fait échouer
la tentative dans une autre région du
hamas en israël via des tunnels
palestiniens le président palestinien
mahmoud abbas
ça a pris la parole disons que la
situation actuelle était un terrorisme
étatique un crime de guerre
le ministère de la santé à gaza avec la
règle que depuis le gué du galbe à 227
palestiniens ont perdu la vie ces fonds
de 164 enfants se sont adonnés des
chiffres globaux vers gaza ne peut plus
rentrer à cause des violences
les organisations des militaires ont
déclaré qu'elles sont du mal à entrer
sur le territoire
les frappes israéliennes continuent
ainsi que les tirs de roquettes
et puis hamas depuis gaza vers israël et
pour l'ajustement pourquoi israël est il
si déterminé à poursuivre l'opération à
gaza
souvent utilisé par les autorités
israéliennes ces nettoyages
il parle de nettoyer gaza ce que cela
signifie c'est qu'il mène des frappes
aériennes visant selon eux les capacités
militaires du hamas
il souhaite détruire autant d'armes
autant d'équipements militaires autant
de l'animation au temps des ressources
du hamas qu'ils peuvent afin de réduire
ses capacités d'attac envers israël nous
avons entendu par exemple d'élégance le
ministre de la défense israélien dire
qu'israël mail a progressé beaucoup dans
sa recherche des réserves dame le
premier ministre israélien a également
déclaré qu'il n'y avait pas de
calendrier vers une fin de l'opération
c'est également un sujet de critiques
intérieures il ya du soutien au sein
d'israël pour cette opération et
benyamin nétanyahou en profitent autant
que possible en encourageant l'opération
et en assurant aux israéliens qu'ils
seront en sécurité les autorités mais
interdisent qui les évalue la situation
et se demandent quand il pourrait y
avoir un cessez le feu peut être dans
les jours à venir
il y aura sans doute une flambée de
violence suivie par un cessez le feu
c'est ainsi que cela se passe en france
lorsqu'il ya en israël lorsqu'il ya des
conflits entre hamas et israël
merci beaucoup paul ailleurs journaliste
pour rta internationale en direct de tel
aviv ce soir et pour approfondir le
sujet nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
nationale bon soin aux blanches maison
merci d'être avec nous on en parlait il
ya quelques instants avec paula joe
biden qui a appelé une désescalade dès
aujourd'hui dans ce conflit
israélo-palestinien on attendait
beaucoup cette prise de parole du
président américain à qui une fois n'est
pas coutume durci le ton envers le
premier ministre de l'état hébreu
oui joe biden et est soumis à une forte
pression
d'abord sur le plan interne puisque
certains membres du congrès de son parti
du parti démocrate commence à dire que
cela suffit de l'une des représentantes
de new york à la chambre des
représentants il était hier matin
bien sûr israël a le droit de se
défendre mais est ce que les
palestiniens ont le droit de survivre
est en effet une partie de la presse
commence à poser aussi la question dans
ces termes
avec aussi la situation sanitaire dans
la bande de gaza qui est totalement
catastrophique donc la pression interne
s'accroît sur le plan externe les états
unis sont relativement isolé puisque par
trois fois ils ont dû utiliser leur veto
au conseil de sécurité des nations unies
contre les 14 autres membres y compris
les quatre membres permanents la chine
la russie la france la grande-bretagne
et les dix autres membres non permanents
et puis on voit bien que les pays arabes
se mobilisent que là les pays arabes
notamment l'egypte qui peut parler aux
deux parties
c'est à dire à la fois au gouvernement
netanyahu et au hamas ce qui n'est pas
le cas des états unis ce qui n'est pas
le cas de l'allemagne ce qui n'est pas
le cas de beaucoup de gens et bien agit
actuellement et mène une véritable
médiation
donc en effet le président des états
unis considèrent que peut-être il est
temps maintenant d'arriver à un cessez
le feu mais il ya un mais il ne veut pas
lâcher netanyahu et ils considèrent que
les états unis ne doivent pas gêner
netanyahu et lui a encore téléphoné
aujourd'hui et d'état netanyahu à a
redit ce qu'il est d'habitude c'est à
dire que le cessez-le-feu viendra en
temps opportun il a dit vous l'avez
montré dans votre sujet
il gardait toutes les options ouvertes
la dissuasion puisqu'il appelle l'action
militaire actuelle une dissuasion et la
lutte poutre pour l'éradication complète
du hamas par conséquent la position
américaine n'a pas encore suffisamment
d'effets sur l'état des eaux l'onu
toujours un peu blanche et on en a déjà
parlé ensemble l'onu dans tout ça qu'ils
n'arrivent toujours pas à apaiser la
situation malgré les réunions
successives
oui bien sûr mais les choses évoluent
puisque aujourd'hui circuler au conseil
de sécurité une résolution préparée par
la france une résolution pas un projet
de un projet de déclaration résolution
c'est contraignant et a été préparé avec
l'aide de l'egypte de la jordanie et de
la tunisie la tunisie est actuellement
un membre non permanent et il est
probable qu'elle viendra en discussion
dans les prochaines heures
nouvelle initiative d'un certain nombre
de pays qui de toute façon veulent
contourner ce blocage le conseil de
sécurité en évoquant dès demain le sujet
à l'assemblée générale l'assemblée
générale peut en effet se saisir à la
demande d'un certain nombre des membres
des nations unies d'un sujet et ce sera
le cas et il est possible que une venus
re une déclaration soit votée par
l'assemblée générale
bien sûr ça n'a aucune valeur
contraignante mais sera incertaine
effets politiques et on peut penser que
en effet à ce moment là le moment sera
peut-être venu pour les états unis
d'obtenir de monsieur netanyahu qu'il
cesse ses bombardements et que l'on
passe à la phase suivante c'est à dire à
la face du magny terre parce que gaza
est complètement détruit parce que
toutes les infrastructures sont
détruites vous avez dit qu'il y avait 2
120 morts et que effectivement monsieur
netanyahou a plus ou moins rempli ses
objectifs ses objectifs militaires qui
était d'affaiblir au maximum
le hamas s'est fait ces objectifs
politiques qui était de démontrer que
c'était lui le hamas qui finalement
déterminé
le rythme des opérations et qui
finalement avait le dernier mot
justement cette nouvelle phase peut être
une trêve un israël d'ailleurs dit
étudier la possibilité d'un cessez le
feu est ce qu'on peut vraiment y croire
ce qu'on se dirige vers cette accalmie
écoutez je pense que le temps le temps
est venu où en effet dans les d'ici la
fin de la semaine
il est probable qu'on arrivera à une
trêve et à une accalmie
encore une fois la catastrophe
humanitaire joue un rôle important parce
que toutes les organisations des nations
unies qui sont dans gaza les
organisations non gouvernementales aussi
qu'ils sont dans gaza montre par là leur
déclaration et parler les photos par les
films l'état de la catastrophe
humanitaire et il faut absolument que
ces bombardements cessent et que l'on
passe à la phase suivante alors il y
aura une phase politique bien sûr comme
le dit monsieur mahmoud abbas mais ça
sera très difficile d'y parvenir et dans
l'immédiat il faut absolument qui est
une phase humanitaire dans laquelle les
organisations spécialisées interviennent
à la fois sur le plan sanitaire
sur le plan éducatif et reconstruisent
finalement les infrastructures
essentielles à la survie dans gaza clown
blanc maison à qui profite finalement ce
conflit écoutez j'ai je suis tenté de
vous dire
avantage aux palestiniens pourquoi et
bien parce que finalement comme vous
l'avez vu hier il ya eu une grève des
palestiniens de tous les palestiniens
dans la bande de gaza mais aussi en
cisjordanie dont jérusalem est mais
aussi dans les villes d'israël où il y à
des arabes qui vivent qu'ils vivaient là
depuis toujours et c'est la première
fois depuis une trentaine d'années qui
lie à une grève de ce genre qui mobilise
tous les palestiniens
on pourrait dire finalement que
netanyahou a réussi ce tour de force un
peu contre productif pour lui de
rassembler elle les palestiniens et puis
la deuxième le deuxième chose c'est que
dans le fond le projecteur a été mis sur
cette affaire palestinienne qui était un
petit peu oublié dans les airs dans les
affaires internationales et sur la
solution à deux à deux états est
finalement monsieur netanyahou
n'échappera pas à ce que les futurs
résolution des nations unies mentionne à
nouveau la solution à deux états et
demande que les conversations reprennent
à ce sujet pour véritablement construire
une solution à deux états c'était ce
qu'avait établi des accords d'oslo
un certain nombre de gens considéraient
que c'était tout à fait périmés qu'il
fallait être réaliste qu'il fallait
passer à autre chose bien il est bien
possible que ce qui se passe depuis dix
jours démontrent le contraire
merci claude blanchemaison vous restez
avec nous si vous le voulez bien puisque
nous allons parler dans quelques
instants avec vous également du sommet
de l'article 1 puisque les députés
russes ont voté ce mercredi le projet de
loi sur le retrait de moscou du traité
de surveillance militaire ciel ouvert un
accord déjà dénoncées par la russie
l'année dernière suite à la sortie des
états unis ce vote intervient à quelques
heures de la tout première rencontre des
chefs de la diplomatie des deux pays
sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken en
fait le point avec leila sarah une
sortie de plus en plus certaine les
députés de la douma ont voté
favorablement pour le retrait de la
russie du traité de surveillance
militaire ciel ouvert cet accord signé
en 1992 permettait aux pays signataires
d'effectuer des vols d'observation et de
surveillance sur la totalité du
territoire des états parties
la chambre haute du parlement doit
maintenant se positionner sur le texte
avant une possible promulgation par
vladimir poutine
les états unis avaient quitté cet accord
sous la
danse de donald trump mais la semaine
dernière washington a affirmé avoir
entamé un réexamen de ce retrait en
privant les avions russes de ciel ouvert
d'accès à leur espace aérien
les etats unis se sont réservé la
possibilité de recevoir de leurs alliés
au sein de l'otan
les matériaux accumulés lors de leur vol
de surveillance au dessus de la russie
après l'entrée en fonction de joseph
byden sont apparus les informations
concernant une modification éventuelle
de l' approche américaine de la
participation au traité
compte tenu de ces éléments nous avons
fait comprendre aux américains de
manière officielle que en cas de
résolution constructive de cette
question la russie pourrait examiner la
possibilité de rester membre du traité
ciel ouvert malheureusement à ce jour
nous n'avons pas reçu de réponse claire
des états unis le vote des députés
russes intervient à quelques heures de
la rencontre des chefs de la diplomatie
des deux pays sergueï lavrov et anthony
blinken
une rencontre qui se déroulera ce
mercredi soir en islande pour aborder
les tensions diplomatiques autour de
l'arctique
les activités militaires dans cette zone
géographique sera l'origine d'un
raidissement entre les pays riverains
notamment le déploiement par l'armée
russe d'un système de défense aérien
dernier cri ainsi que des manoeuvres à
grande échelle dans les eaux polaires
les forces armées américaines et de
l'otan ont pris l'habitude de réaliser
des manoeuvres régulière en solitaire ou
de manière groupée de navires de guerre
de surface
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis les temps
qui ont suivi la deuxième guerre
mondiale
de telles actions un caractère
provocateur et un effet négatif sur la
sécurité régionale dans son ensemble un
fossé sans précédent c'est par les deux
puissances rivales
medjo byden et vladimir poutine semblent
d'accord pour organiser un premier
sommet bilatéral en juin dans un pays
européens et qui devrait se tenir dans
la foulée des réunions du g7 et de
l'otan oui nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales toute
blanche maison pourquoi l'article et il
l'objet de tant de convoitises
d'abord l'article présente une
particularité c'est que il n'y a pas de
traité international qui régissent le
statut de l'arctique alors il y en a
pour l'antarctique
et c'est parce qu'il ya une différence
fondamentale cet article c'est un
continent des montagnes qui émerge du
fond de la mer alors que l'article ça
n'est pas le cas c'est une banquise qui
flotte sur l'océan et la deuxième raison
c'est que il y a des richesses
considérables dans le sous-sol de
l'arctique et que le réchauffement
climatique fait que l'exploitation si
richesse devient plus facile
c'est à dire moins coûteux la troisième
raison c'est que les grands sont en face
à face autour de l'arctique puisqu'il ya
d'un côté la très grande façade nord de
la russie
et puis de l'autre côté il ya l'alaska
et le canada + 5 autres pays d'europe du
nord qui sont les voisins du cercle
polaire et qui par conséquent sont
riverains de l'océan arctique
alors tout son désintérêt
particuliers et certains d'entre eux
évidemment auront aussi souhaité étendre
leur zone économique exclusive puisque
comme il n'y a pas de traité régissant
ce continent qui n'existent pas eh bien
c'est le droit de la mer qui s'applique
le traité sur le droit de la mer est en
vigueur depuis 1992 et qui permet aux
aux états d'étendre leurs zones
économiques exclusives à 200 milles
marins de la côte est d'ailleurs 350 km
15 km 15 milles marins par dont la lame
hervé territoriale 350 kilomètres la
zone économique exclusive et quand
lorsque deux zones économiques
exclusives viennent en contradiction et
bien on s'assoit et on négocie
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans un certain
nombre de cas mais pas dans tous les cas
dans l'arctique et par conséquent il y à
là avec des bases militaires
du côté russe comme du côté américain un
enjeu important qui est un enjeu global
avec pour tout le monde
l'enjeu de la liberté de circulation
dans les mers et encore une fois avec le
réchauffement climatique
l'ouverture de la route du nord qui fait
que l'europe peut être rallier par
bateau à l'asie en une durée de temps
beaucoup au moins longue qu'en passant
par le canal de suez et par conséquent
un certain nombre de pays veulent se
positionner sur cette route y compris
d'ailleurs la chine qui n'a pas de
façade sur l'océan arctique mais qui
considère qu'elle a un intérêt direct à
ce qui se passe dans l'océan arctique et
qui construit d'ailleurs des brise
glaces pour exporter sa flotte
quelles sont les revendications des pays
voisins
alors d'abord la norvège très sagement a
conclu un accord avec la russie en 2010
pour régler tous les problèmes de
délimitation de zones maritimes zone
économique exclusive zones de pêche
la norvège est un cas un peu particulier
parce que très au nord elle possède un
archipel qui s'appelle les salles baard
eker archipel absolument stratégique
dans la position il se trouve et qu'elle
tenait à garder une zone de pêche autour
de cet archipel
et puis d'en garder le contrôle un
accord est intervenu avec la russie et
par conséquent la norvège maintenant n'a
plus de revendications particulières
la russie a déposé il ya quelques années
un dossier auprès de l' agence de l'onu
qui s'occupe de l'application du traité
sur le droit de la mer pour expliquer
que une épine sous-marine qu'on appelle
la dorsale de lomonosov parts et
perpendiculairement à la côte de sibérie
vers le pôle nord et que par conséquent
cette épine dorsale de donner droit à la
russie un plateau continental allant au
delà de la zone les 200000 dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
donc c'est 7 7 de 7
cette demande a fait l'objet d'une
instruction qui n'a pas tout juste qu'il
n'a pas encore débouché en 2007
d'ailleurs la russie a monté une
expédition au pôle nord avec le célèbre
spécialiste des pôles monsieur schilling
a rohff et cette expédition s'est
illustré entre autres en envoyant un
sous-marin planté un drapeau sous sur le
reçu exactement alors à l'endroit où il
est convenu de considérer que c'est le
pôle le pôle étant à 4000 mètres sous le
niveau de la mer alors il ya d'autres
revendications
le danemark a des revendications au nom
du groenland puisque c'est de la marque
administre le groenland lalala le canada
et les états unis
ils n'ont pas encore ratifié le traité
sur le roi de la mer ont également des
rangs des ratifications
autre hit de l'extension de leurs
plateaux territoriales donc ça ce sont
les revendications juridique mais qui
s'accompagne naturellement de conception
un petit peu différente s'ils ont la
liberté de navigation dans toute cette
zone puisque cette zone en réalité
fait partie de la route mère lorsqu'elle
le nepad en une dans une zone économique
exclusive et que la navigation est
totalement libre que les sous-marins
probablement ils circulent en toute
liberté
qui dit sous marins indiens évidemment
question stratégique craie blanche
maison lors de ce sommet anthony blinken
et sergueï lavrov vont s'entretenir lors
d'une réunion d'anticipation à la
rencontre byden poutine prévue au mois
de juin
de quoi vont-ils bien pouvoir parler
alors il ya deux schémas pour la
rencontre lavrov lesquels il ya le
schéma conflictuel dans le fondre
monsieur lavrov a donné l'exemple avec
monsieur borel avec le représentant de
l'union européenne et puis dont monsieur
blinken a donné l'exemple avec deux
mises affaires étrangères chinois là je
pense que ça ne sera pas le cas je pense
que monsieur oublie qu'elle veut
préparer sérieusement avec monsieur
lavrov
la rencontre entre le président poutine
et le président joe biden
les enjeux sont évidemment considérable
et il ya donc là encore encore deux
autres deux hypothèques à lever est ce
que on cherchera à discuter d'abord des
sujets sur lesquels on peut trouver un
accord
ou est-ce qu'on cherchera surtout à
discuter des sujets qui fâchent
gilles façon les connaît c'est les
droits de l'homme c'est la vallée c'est
la biélorussie éventuellement d'ukraine
il faudra bien d'en parler mais on peut
aussi parler de sujets sur lesquels la
russie et les etats unis ont un intérêt
commun
d'abord il ya tous les sujets
stratégiques puisque ce n'était pas par
hasard que joe biden a prolongé dès son
arrivée à la maison blanche pour cinq
ans le traité new start qui limite le
nombre d'ogives nucléaires et le nombre
de missiles de fusées intercontinentales
pour les lancer par contre il ne semble
pas que les etats unis soient intéressés
à revenir à ressusciter le traité
sur les armes nucléaires intermédiaires
qui a été dénoncé par monsieur trump hui
à la suite parlée par les russes
et aujourd'hui on n'entend qu'eux il en
va de même pour le traiter à ciel ouvert
ces traités avait un intérêt c'est
qu'ils sont tous et contiennent tous un
élément de des changes de surveillance
et que dans le fond pour créer de la
confiance entre des rivaux stratégique
il faut certainement prévoir des mesures
de surveillance et peut-être que c'est
un sujet que monsieur blinken et
monsieur lavrov évoqueront tout à
l'heure alors il ya beaucoup d'autres
sujets qui peuvent être évoqués bien
entendu le réchauffement climatique
ça paraît banal mais c'est quand même
tout à fait vitale d'autant plus que
dans le nord de la russie
le permafrost est en train de fondre que
ça met en péril un certain nombre
d'infrastructures y compris les gazoducs
et que en revanche par contre ça
permettra sans doute à la russie
d'étendre sa zone cultivable et par
conséquent sa production agricole dans
les 25 ans qui viennent
tout se sait tout sur tous ces sujets
une coopération est possible ce ne sont
pas des sujets conflictuels la
cybersécurité c'est un autre sujet qui
fait beaucoup parler mais après tout
d'un côté comme de l'autre on a
peut-être besoin d'avoir des codes
communs des grilles de lecture qu'il
fasse que l'on ne puisse pas s'accuser
de n'importe quelle attaque et qu'on
puisse essayer d'établir un minimum de
cyber sécurité dans le monde
surtout qu'actuellement en effet des
opérateurs privés peuvent remonter des
prêts facilement des offensives et des
actions très destructive
alors on verra ce que ce que ça oui
pardonnez moi je voulais pas vous couper
la chique aussi brutalement mon arrivée
à la fin de cette heure merci en tout
cas on a compris le débat et on verra
effectivement à ce qu'il en ressortira
de ces sujets avec cette réunion entre
les deux hommes ce soir merci à vous
dans quelques instants
elle reste avec nous reviendrons sur la
réouverture des terrasses et les lieux
culturels les prémices du déconfinement
ans qu'il était bien accueillie par les
restaurateurs et le pass anitele riches
shit la polémique adopté par le sénat
cette nuit ce sera l'objet de notre
débat
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il soutint encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'ils
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui révèle il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vie des idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des lignes aujourd'hui on a une
gauche extrêmement sujet de la télé tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 19 mai emmanuel macron et son
premier ministre avait convoqué les
caméras télévision ce matin pour la
deuxième phase du déconfinement
aujourd'hui café en terrasse pour les
deux hommes commerce inné et musées ont
aussi rouvert leurs portes après six
mois de fermeture dans le même temps les
sénateurs ont adopté cette nuit en
première lecture la sortie de l'état
d'urgence et le pass sanitaire décidé
adoptés en france les européens ne
parviennent pas à se mettre d'accord sur
le certificat sanitaire européen
il faciliterait les déplacements au sein
même de l'union européenne pendant la
saison touristique estivale
les discussions devraient reprendre
demain son fonctionnement serait le même
que le certificat français attester
d'une vaccination contre le comique 19
dantès négatif ou d'une immunité après
une injection un nouveau procès s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire
contre lyon soro l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale condamné à 20 ans
de prison l'année dernière est poursuivi
avec 19 de ses proches pour complot
contre la sûreté de l'état
participation à une bande armée et
détention illégale d'armes
l'une des accusées répondre à nos
questions dans cette édition
[Musique]
en france deuxième étape de la levée des
restrictions annoncées par le
gouvernement avec la réouverture des
terrasses la sortie de l'état d'urgence
et le passé ni terre ont été adoptées
dans la nuit en première lecture par les
sénateurs français est la rentrée est en
vigueur prévue le 9 juin en france et à
partir du 20 juin pour les déplacements
en europe
aymen macro et jean castex ont eux aussi
pris un café en terrasse son premier
jour de leur réouverture
si les clients étaient sous la pluie
mais heureux de retrouver un souffle de
liberté les restaurateurs eux se sont
réjouis de voir leur établissement
reprendre vie après un arrêt de neuf
mois ils peuvent enfin retrouver leurs
clients mais avec une capacité d'accueil
à 50 % voici quelques réactions
ça fait plaisir d'accueillir un peu nos
clients qu'on voyait pas ce qu'il me
demande à chaque fois quand est-ce qu'on
allait revenir
e
je pense que cette semaine ça est un peu
sport mais à partir de la semaine
prochaine tout devrait se passer
normalement
drogba détendre potocki
c'est surtout ça
attaquer vraiment
je travaille dans les boulangeries salué
dans la voiture donc c'était papa c'est
quoi donc il a le fait qu'en ce groupe
là comme ça ça fait du bien
ça manquait un peu quoi
un petit café avant de partir travailler
c'est resté non je m'appuie moins
paris 6 2
[Musique]
yves est rentré dans les bars le soir du
concert
cent cinquante mille commerce non
essentiels rouvre également il en est de
même pour les musées ou encore les
salles de cinéma déconfinement acte 2
modes d'emploi en images avec elvire le
doré à compter de ce mercredi le
couvre-feu est décalée de 19h à 21h les
cinémas peuvent rouvrir avec une
capacité d'accueil de 35 %
800 spectateurs au maximum et deux
fauteuils libre entre chaque spectateur
où chaque groupe
ces conditions s'appliquent aux autres
types de salles de spectacles les musées
doivent assurer huit mètres carrés par
visiteur et les bibliothèques trouvera
également à raison d'un siège sur deux
les festivals en plein air sont
autorisés jusqu'à 1000 personnes assises
avec une jauge de 35% réouverture aussi
avec des jauges réduite toujours des
parcs zoologiques en plein air 50% et
des casinos 35%
seuls les terrasses des bars et
restaurants sont concernés par une
réouverture à 50% de leurs capacités et
avec des tables jusqu'à 6 personnes
les hôtels peuvent également ouvrir leur
restaurant intérieure mais uniquement
dans le cadre des séjours tout compris
les commerces et rayons dit non
essentiels rouvre à condition de
respecter la distanciation de 8 mètres
carrés par client mesure toujours
valable dans les centres commerciaux les
activités sportives collectives en plein
air sont à nouveau autorisés jusqu'à 10
personnes uniquement sans contact les
compétitions sportives amateurs peuvent
être réorganisée sans contact dans une
jauge maximale de 50 personnes les
établissements sportifs extérieurs comme
les stades ou couverts comme les
piscines peuvent accueillir des
spectateurs dans la limite de 30 5% de
l'effectif jusqu'à 1000 personnes
assises
concernant la pratique seuls les publics
prioritaires scolaires sportifs
professionnels
sont autorisés à reprendre leurs
activités pour les mariages et les pacs
la jauge passe à 30 100 % de la capacité
d'accueil du lieu de réception
les cérémonies funéraires peuvent elles
accueillir jusqu'à 50 personnes
les résidents des établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes des unités de soins de
longue durée et des résidences autonomie
peuvent à nouveau recevoir des visites
et se rendre à l'extérieur
parmi les mesures qui reste pour le
moment en vigueur le télétravail ou
encore les rassemblements de plus de dix
personnes sont toujours interdits dans
l'espace public est une deuxième étape
du déconfinement qui a donné lieu à une
grosse séquence de communication
gouvernementale aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron sur le terrain à la terrasse d'un
café ce matin avec jean cassettes pour
la réouverture est dans les salles et
sur les terrains de foot cet après midi
pour la reprise du sport alors est ce le
retour vraiment progressif à une vie
vraiment normal pas si sûr en tout cas
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage ce
soir
[Musique]
avec nous pourrons parler alexis poulain
notre éditorialiste bonsoir alexis denis
jacquet entrepreneurs et auteur vous
oubliez covin le début de la peur la
faim d'une démocratie aux éditions
eyrolles et enfin et christophe sira
restaurateurs et représentants du
collectif les pendus bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors c'est une image qui a
évidemment fait le tour de toutes les
chaînes de télévision ce matin ce tête à
tête entre emmanuel macron et jean
castex le président le premier ministre
regarder devant les caméras pour prendre
un petit café en terrasse heureusement
il ne pleuvait pas ils ont eu de la
chance c'était les cinq minutes
d'accalmie de la journée alexis pour
l'un elle montre quoi cette image un
tandem à la tête de l'exécutif qui a
réussi le déconfinement et qui marche
bien alors oui elle montre finalement
l'inanité de la communication politique
quand on est né est réduit à se filmer à
prendre un café en terrasse alors qu'ils
prennent des cafés sur les terrasses des
hôtels de la république que sont
l'elysée ou matignon où on peut tout à
fait avoir son café entre le président
et le premier ministre à l'abri des
regards là il fallait se montrer il
fallait dire allez c'est parti on peut y
aller bruno le maire aussi ses prix sur
une terrasse le ministre des transports
monsieur djebbari le ministre du
tourisme pour tout le monde tout le
gouvernement était sur une terrasse avec
un café à l'abri des gouttes d'ailleurs
ça montre simplement que ceux qui nous
ont enfermés ceux qui ont fermé les
commerces dits non essentiel pendant de
longs mois se mettre en scène comme les
grand libérateur parce qu'ils ont décidé
que aujourd'hui c'était le jour où ça
prouverait rien de prouvé que c'était
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment une fois
encore décidé dans le cercle très fermé
un des conseils de défense sanitaire
aucun vote aucune transparence sur ces
jugements du l'épidémiologiste en chef
et donc on se met en scène comme
libérateur alarcon et ceux qui font que
les libertés ont été réduites alors sous
prétexte sanitaires
mais moi qui suis à rome j'ai vu que ça
fait plus de 15 jours que les bars
ouverts également et il n'y a aucun
problème aujourd'hui
l'angleterre qui a ouvert avant nous
alors boris johnson a dit attention
peut-être qu'un variant va arriver pour
la clairement on est dans la séquence
ouverture libération donc le
gouvernement se met en scène mais c'est
un peu ridicule c'est un peu suranné je
ne sais pas si ça marche toujours est il
que ça nous a donné une belle séquence
évidemment de communication politique et
peut-être donné l'idée d'aller en
terrasse des fois qu'on en ait eu besoin
d'avoir cette idée alors au delà des
manuels macro ans est carrément
plusieurs membres du gouvernement qui se
sont affichées sur les réseaux sociaux
ce matin le maître mot semble avoir été
donnée regarder ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire le ministre l'économie
agnès pannier rue nash et ça fait
vraiment publicité de vacances au monde
a l'air si détendu le jeune le duo formé
par le secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes et celui aux transports
clément bonnet jean baptiste djebbari
denis jacquet vous qui avez l'habitude
ces opérations de communication dans le
pays des états unis avec lequel vous
faites souvent l'aller-retour une
opération de communication massif comme
ça ça vous inspire quoi vous avec alexis
jeu on en est rendu à faire de quasiment
de la télé réalité alors bon on aura pu
voir de dos que les costumes de jean
castex sont toujours d'une même qualité
donc au moins une constance dans cette
voie de ce truc là c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que de l'autre côté pour
personnellement si on m'avait demandé de
faire l'exercice j'aurais été un peu
choqué de le faire un moment donné où
est à 80 % des restaurateurs français
sont encore fermés et doivent se dire
que cette belle séquence d'ouverture
elle concerne quoi les 17% de
restaurateurs ou 20% qui ont une
terrasse en france pendant que les
autres pour des raisons tout à fait
complètement et qui reste
incompréhensible maintenant alors on
pouvait en douter il ya un an on n'avait
pas les statistiques mais maintenant
c'est très bien que avoir observé le
monde entier notamment pour moi pour mon
bouquin je sais qu'aujourd'hui les
restaurateurs n'étaient pas une facteur
majeur de
2-2 de contamination au pti de ce virus
qu'ils auraient pu rester ouverts et en
tout cas est très ouvert plus tôt il
aurait pu être tous rouvert en même
temps et là j'aurais compris que notre
président et son premier ministre et
tout son gouvernement et prendre un café
avec des airs de libérateur poste 1945
donc oui je trouve ça un peu suranné un
peu ridicule et un peu angoissant et
même énervant pour ceux aujourd'hui qui
sont toujours fermés qui se demandent
pourquoi parce que tout à l'heure bon
j'étais interviewé pour une émission qui
se passait bien évidemment terrasse
puisque pratiquement 80% des émissions
elles aussi sont en terrasse donc merci
de nous avoir gardé au chaud ce soir
parce qu'il fait pas très chaud à paris
mais là on avait soi-disant ham 1 1 m
huit mètres carrés pour une personne je
peux vous dire qu'à paris ou à nice où
sont mes amis et une partie de la
famille c'est plutôt huit personnes sur
1 mètre carré donc ça doit énerver pas
mal on verra tout à l'heure les
restaurateurs qui sont sur ce plateau ce
soir on va même la voir dans une seconde
puisqu'on en a parmi nos christophe
chirat vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse de données
jacques et ça vous aurait fait plaisir
on par exemple emmanuel macron et et
jean castex a déboulé sur votre terrasse
vous les auriez vous auriez accueilli
comment ça m'aurait pas tellement j'ai
plaisir parce que vous savez c'est
vraiment effectivement cette mise en
scène de libérateur alors qu'en fait ma
perception un mot c'est plutôt
l'assassin qui revient sur les lieux de
son crime
en fait c'est très humiliant ces
conditions de réouverture on autorise
seulement les terrasses et seulement
avec une jauge et seulement avec ceux ci
et seulement avec cela moi j'espérais
une petite une vraie réhabilitation ça
fait des mois qu'on nous discriminent
comme disait mon collègue précédemment
le sans raison en tout cas sans aucune
raison scientifique il roulait c'est
tout le monde le sait maintenant c'est
plus du tout du complotisme c'est une
réhabilitation dont on a besoin parce
que les gens ont aussi besoin de venir
chez nous en confiance alors qu'on leur
a fait peur depuis 15 mois et c'est pas
gagné et je crois pas qu'aujourd'hui les
terrasses étaient si remplie que ça de
gens qui sont allés déjeuner au
restaurant
outre la météo qui évidemment avec 13
degrés comme vous disiez les photos sont
intéressantes on dirait des photos de
vacances mais des vacances au ski et le
cadre est différent voyez c'est pas le
même là on est sur les terrasses
parisiennes
c'est lamentable on fait ça veut rien
dire c'est cette année espèce de l'air
effectivement il ya 80% de deux d'entre
nous qui reste cher mais j'en fais
partie et pourtant j'ai une terrasse
j'ai deux cents mètres carrés de
terrasse voyez j'ai fait le choix de
padar ouvrir parce que les conditions
d'exploitation seront beaucoup trop
aléatoire et notamment la météo et
honnêtement on mérite mieux que ça oui
il ya plusieurs réactions un pronostic
je voudrais vous les faire écouter celle
de gilbert collard eurodéputés rennes
suivie de celle de nadine morano
eurodéputés l air ce matin
macron et castex s'exhibe en terrasse
pour prendre un café
quand donc la mise en scène de ces
clowns de la communication
s'arrêtera-t-elle est urgent alors que
la gestion de la crise sanitaire a été
un véritable fiasco emmanuel macron
vient boire son petit café à gros
renfort de caméras immense opération de
com pour un retour à une vie juste
normal du à tous les français alexis
boulaire leur ensemble beaucoup de
sévérité de la part des politiques
l'opposition bien évidemment qui est
dans son rôle mais aussi sur ce plateau
et pourtant c'est vrai que les chaînes
de télévision ce matin voilà avait des
airs de libération est ce que les
français sont dupes où le soulagement
finalement prévaut sur le reste on
oublie les mauvais souvenirs et on
profite
ça valait s'est taillé une volonté oui
je pense qu'il ya une volonté de passer
à autre chose même si c'est autre chose
on n'est pas sûr parce que malgré la
vaccination qui s'accélère il faut
garder le masque il faut garder la
distanciation physique on est toujours
dans dans ses ordres qui sont des
comptes rendre
donc il faut aller en terrasse comme il
fallait aller en théâtre avant de
confier une semaine plus tard mais
faites attention quand même donc on est
loin de retrouver la vie d'avant et
c'est ça que je pensais le plus cruel
c'est de faire croire qu'on va retrouver
une vie d'avant alors qu'il n'en est
rien qu'on est toujours dans une vie
qu'ovide avec de nombreux gens qui sont
aujourd'hui en réanimation avec toujours
des taux assez élevé en france notamment
donc on se demande pourquoi tout cela
fait si ce n'est pour pousser le temps
puisque emmanuel macron veut reprendre
la main sur les horloges lancer la
campagne des municipales s'assurer aussi
le lancement de sa campagne
présidentielle se mettre en scène comme
le grandit
orateur alors qu'il est évidemment celui
qui a mis l'économie à l'arrêt celui qui
a fermé les commerces sont essentielles
de manière totalement péremptoire c'est
à dire qu'il ya eu aucun débat il ya eu
aucune façon de faire le choix de en
janvier de ne pas confiné en dix ans et
y ait un petit chemin pour finalement
arriver à 6 mois de couvre-feu enfin on
vit on vit dans un monde totalement
absurde 1 depuis un an alors on nous dit
que c'est pour des raisons sanitaires
mais quand même on est en droit de se
demander si c'est justifié à ce point là
est aujourd'hui arrivé effectivement
comme ça à se mettre en scène en
terrasse pour dire allez c'est parti
allons-y c'est un peu la méthode coué
avec un bruno le maire qui passe son
temps à parler de rebond à dire que la
croissance va exploser dès que les
magasins vont rouvrir
or compte tenu de la chute du pib de 8,4
pour cent l'an dernier
si on a la chance de rattraper les
wagons ce sera le minimum mais déjà de
nombreux établissements au prévu de
fermer le monde de la nuit est
totalement oubliée et plein d'autres
secteurs s'en sont aussi oublié de ces
mesures
on sait très bien que les mesures aussi
de soutien à l'économie vont
progressivement disparaître
hélas hélas le choc sera terrible on
décale simplement le choc des faillites
en sachant très bien qu'elle seront
nombreuses malheureusement et que de
nombreux établissements ne vont pas
pouvoir et ouvrir parce que c'est
impossible compte tenu du climat compte
tenu aussi de ces mois de non activité
forcé par cet exécutif qui aujourd'hui
se met en scène comme les grands
sauveurs denis jacquet ce que vous
partagez l'analyse alexis poulain parce
que c'est vrai que le gouvernement
s'emploie à faire oublier les mauvais
souvenirs qu'ils soient encore
évidemment très récent et on entendait
aussi le ministre de l'économie nous
dire que ce sera le retour de la
croissance de manière assez forte ce qui
a quand même cette heureuse possibilité
pourquoi pas alors tout d'abord c'est
vrai que avant de penser à la vie
d'avant malheureusement et je vais être
un peu pessimiste mais il faut penser à
la mort d'après ces terres que la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui les
problèmes sont cachés sous les tapis à
et que ce tapis va être soulevée ces
terres qu une fois que l'activité va
reprendre les mesures de perfusion ont
cessé les aides vont s'arrêter
et c'est là on va voir la véritable
réalité de ce qui est devenu l'économie
française mais aussi d'autres pays dans
ces derniers mois on sait que la chine
est reparti à fond on sait que les états
unis dans un premier temps
art relativement rapidement mais où
aussi des problèmes de recrutement 1 c
'est le compte qu'on a en occident
aujourd'hui europe et etats unis c'est à
dire qu'on reprend mais les gens ne
veulent pas venir travailler aux états
unis pour différentes raisons qu'on
pourra évoquer plus tard mais en tout
cas il ya un vrai problème qui pourrait
pénaliser la nar croissance économique
ce qu'on n'avait pas prévu ça non c'est
à dire grosse croissance à la fin ou
petite croissance
et là on se dit ah il y aurait
éventuellement une grosse croissance
mais on a plus personne pour l'alimenter
lorsque vous états unis notamment les
gens ne veulent pas reprendre des
emplois qui sont en contact avec le
public parce qu'ils ont encore peur et
en france les systèmes dead font
qu'aujourd'hui tous ceux qui peuvent
rester encore au chômage ou dans des
systèmes d'adp le reste et ne veulent
pas y aller donc le début du déclin de
la fonte de la banquise qui va révéler
la réalité c'est maintenant et donc on
va voir donc d'un côté oui il y aura une
forte croissance
parce qu'il ya un besoin de consommation
une envie de consommation une épargne
qui a été constituée pendant tous ces
mois mais les gens vont commencer à les
dépenser un peu ça c'est clair
puis d'endo deuxième temps ils
arrêteront parce que des chiffres vont
apparaître
evo déroule à l'âge arrêtent de dépenser
comme une commune cigale et je vite
redevenir fourmies et puis surtout il y
aura j'espère un moment de vérité qui
sera double premier set dire on a géré
cette crise en technocrate et pas en
homme de réalisme il va falloir un jour
faire un petit peu le procès de ce qui a
été fait aujourd'hui parce que je trouve
que c'est très grave
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'on va
aussi comme disait monsieur de
restaurateurs à voir la réalité
scientifique c'est aujourd'hui vous
prenez la suède qui n'a jamais confiné
vous prenez l'asie vous prenez l'afrique
et vous prenez même aux etats-unis new
york et san francisco qui ont un peu
confiné miami houston qui ont jamais
confiné même taux de mortalité mais la
grande différence entre les deux c'est
que le lien sont dans un dessin une semi
situation de désarroi des causes
économiques alors que les autres ont
repris à toute vitesse donc je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup c'est le début de
l'heure du bilan
je pense que malheureusement après une
période d'euphorie et de kiva koudouss
conjuguer avec l'été les dépenses d'été
stival ou à tout cela chez un petit peu
le retour à la réalité à la rentrée sera
un peu différent et offrir à votre
lecture sur le plan économique on sait
que
allait rouvrir avec une jauge de 50% ça
pose d'ailleurs beaucoup de problèmes à
beaucoup de vos collègues comment
rattraper reprendre une activité
rattraper surtout la trésorerie et ne
pas couler dans ces conditions la
trésorerie on va jamais la rattraper
on a bénéficié de certaines aides depuis
le début de cette crise mais qui n'ont
pas été 10 de dimensionner correctement
ni répartie correctement il ya août une
équité dans tout ça pour tous pour ceux
qui en ont bénéficié
beaucoup n'ont pas bénéficié bien sûr
50% de jose je moi je connais personne
qui a cinquante pour cent de bénéfice
net à la fin de son bilan donc ça veut
dire que si on a des capacités de
remplissage c'est pas pour rien c'est
pour équilibrer nos comptes
donc bien sûr que l'état devrait être
présent a déjà prévu de ne pas être
présente ses dents dans deux mois il y
aura plus rien du tout alors
qu'effectivement les contraintes et les
mesures de 2,2 de restrictions vont
perdurer et encore une fois la confiance
des gens ne sera certainement pas au
rendez-vous et bien sûr qu'on aura pas
tous les touristes qu'on avait les
années précédentes
donc économiquement ça va être
effectivement une hécatombe parce que
les les entreprises qui auraient dû
cherche à 8 dans l'année 2020 n'ont pas
fait faillite parce que beaucoup ont été
perfusé comme disait mon prédécesseur
donc on va avoir une certainement en
2021 2022 début 2022 toute une cascade
de faillites de 2022 2021 et 2022 qui
seront directement consécutive par
contre à la crise christophe sira
l'union européenne se prépare justement
ouvrir plus grand ses portes aux
visiteurs étrangers à condition
évidemment d'être vacciné c'est une
décision qui a été prise ces dernières
heures vous n'y croyez pas vous à ces
touristes étrangers dès l'été servent
trop tard bah écoute et on verra
rendez-vous au tas de sable maintenant
j'y crois pas particulièrement cette
histoire de deux pâles sanitaire est
encore par en place n'a pas grand sens
puisque on a rarement ce sont des
garanties scientifiques et médicales
clics ils sont pas de l'objet de ce
débat mais ça n'a pas grand sens
particulier à part se faire plaisir
on va voir comment les jeux les
contrôles vont être opérés d'ailleurs ça
va être drôle
ah bon on est parti dans des
considérations incroyable pour une
maladie quand même et qui avait fait
99,96 % de survivants faut pas l'oublier
ça n'est plus donc on air on subit tout
ça pour ça donc on n'oublie pas les gens
qui sont partis
mais il faut aussi ne pas oublier ceux
qui sont restés ils sont nettement
majoritaires oui merci en tout cas à
tous les 3 alexis poulain christophe
chirac denis jacquet merci d'avoir
accepté ce décryptage en direct sur rt
france ce soir est bonne terrasse à vous
demain matin parce qu'on est en
couvre-feu un oublié par qui a été
repoussée néanmoins à 21h merci à vous
et on en parlait la commissaire
européenne chargée des vaccins âge
peut-être nos troupes stella kyriakidou
est soupçonné de corruption passive dans
son pays lille méditerranée chypre
méditerranéenne chier pour les montants
s'élèvent à 4 millions d'euros nadège
abderrazak c'est une affaire qui
pourrait bien plonger bruxelles dans
l'embarras stella kyriakidou commissaire
européenne chargée de la santé est
soupçonné de corruption passive
un rapport de la cour des comptes
chypriote son pays d'origine
pointent du doigt l'absence de
justification au tour de près de 4
millions d'euros reçus par son mari
entre 2009 et 2017 et qu'il n'a jamais
remboursé les prêts ont été accordés par
la deuxième plus grande banque de chypre
propriété de l'état la cyprus
coopérative banques confrontées à de
graves problèmes financiers
nécessitant plusieurs renflouements par
de l'argent public
la cour des comptes considère qu'il
s'agit de transactions très
problématique
pourquoi parce que kyriacos kyriacou
idoux ne disposerait pas de garanties
suffisantes en termes de revenus ou de
patrimoine pour obtenir des prêts d'une
telle importance
ce rapport sert à fournir des faits et
non à porter des jugements politiques
chaque citoyen peut se forger sa propre
opinion sur la légitimité ou non de
telles transactions
reste que les soupçons sont alimentés
par leur oubli
si on peut dire de stella kyriakidou fou
dans sa déclaration de transparence
parlement européen chypriote n'a en
effet pas mentionné la fonction de
directeur de marc alaux limited exercée
par son mari c'est pourtant au nom de
cette entreprise qu'il a reçu les
différents prêts elle n'a pas non plus
précisé
les autres activités de son mari qui est
directeur ou président de pas moins de
neuf sociétés au total
et si pour l'heure madame kyriakidou
assure n'avoir je cite aucune
implication personnelle dans la
polémique entourant son mari c ommission
fait sortir de sa réserve
un eurodéputé allemand la commissaire
européenne à la santé kyriakidou doit
clarifier cela de toute urgence
son mari est soupçonné de corruption à
chypre et la société de son mari est
absente de la déclaration de
transparence de kyriakidou des questions
auxquelles il faut répondre rapidement
s'agit-il d'une affaire de corruption
passive
ce que l'on sait en tout cas c'est
qu'elle est assez embarrassante pour
celle qui est en première ligne sur la
question des achats de vaccins par l'uae
on se souvient que ses commandes de
l'union avait beaucoup fait jaser
notamment à cause du secret qui a
entouré les négociations sur les prix
mais aussi les conditions d'octroi
on peut néanmoins souligné que ces prêts
contractés par son époux à chypre l'ont
été avant qu'elle ne prenne ses
fonctions à la commission en décembre
2019 et donc avant la crise du
coronavirus si ce scandale de corruption
est avérée il pourrait néanmoins
entachée encore davantage la crédibilité
d'une commission européenne de plus en
plus contesté pas rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous partir en voyage
en europe cet été ça pourrait être
nécessaire de se munir d'un pass
sanitaires pour traverser les frontières
de l'union le sujet est au centre des
discussions parlementaires et puis nous
irons en afrique en côte d'ivoire
précisément où guillaume soro ancien
premier ministre est confronté à une
nouvelle fois la justice
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique non une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
bacs celle là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument importants ainsi que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers que
ça soit le sénégal le nigeria l'afrique
du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition
l'avoir amené la générale de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
ep
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez boxart y allons faire
connaissance vous avez choisi le jour à
bagdad alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylé
fallu les français ne sors pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et ans et demi
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
l'arrivée du coc vite 19 annie bon
nombre d'entreprises en difficulté
comment les sauver faut-il annuler la
dette de certaines entreprises
l'annulation de la dette aura des
conséquences il faut le savoir
on aura des conséquences avec les
banques banques qui étaient déjà pas
bien en avant la crise du coc vide cette
idée de prendre en charge les les la
dette des entreprises
pour moi c'est un peu plus proportions
gardées c'est un peu c'est simple vaccin
du dernier recours
au final on aura exactement comme
d'habitude les mêmes qui vont payer
c'est à dire tous ceux qui payent des
impôts monsieur bruno le maire se prend
pour un type ex il peut y passer toutes
les dettes les dettes de l'état les
dettes des entreprises ecsta simplement
si on se posait la question de ne pas
aller faire les dettes ça serait déjà
pas mal
[Musique]
deux termes banlieue voir l'intensité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et on donne cette
impression de la banlieue ça serait une
vraie cas des jeunes violents contre une
police qui serait son travail c'est plus
compliqué que ça on est français on est
fiers de vivre dans ces quartiers même
s'il ya des difficultés est la moindre
des choses c'est d'inscrire aussi notre
empreinte canton quand on participe à la
vie de la société et malheureusement il
n'y a pas cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent et politique fort
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
arte france si vous nous rejoignez si
l'union européenne a autorisé les
voyageurs étrangers vacciner à pénétrer
sur le territoire européen les 27 ne
parviennent toujours pas à s'accorder
sur un certificat vaccinale unique qui
permettrait une harmonisation des règles
à l'échelle de l'ensemble des pays
membres
une troisième séance de discussion s'est
achevée mardi soir sans succès de
nouvelles négociations sont prévues ce
jeudi helen masquelier érigé en sésame
le passeport vaccinale fait l'objet de
nombreux débats et l'union européenne ne
fait pas exception
la commission a dévoilé son projet de
certificats numériques en mars dernier
gratuit ce certificat prendrait la forme
d'un document doté d'un qr code a
présenté lors des contrôles dans les
pays membres
quel que soit le moyen de transport
utilisé le 29 avril le parlement
européen s'est déjà prononcé en faveur
du dispositif
mais c'est à présent aux états membres
du conseil européen qu'il revient de
ratifier le projet avec la
multiplication des initiatives
nationales en termes de passes
sanitaires l'enjeu est bien d'éviter une
véritable cacophonie européenne
de nombreux états membres ont lancé ou
prévoient de lancer des initiatives
visant à délivrer des certificats de
vaccination
toutefois pour que ces certificats
puisse être utilisé de manière efficace
dans un contexte transfrontières lorsque
les citoyens exercent leur droit à la
libre circulation
ces certificats de vaccination doivent
être pleinement intéropérables
compatible sur et vérifiable une
approche adoptée d'un commun accord
entre les états membres est nécessaire
pour ce qui est du contenu du format des
principes des normes techniques et du
niveau de protection de ces certificats
si cet outil visera surtout à faciliter
la vie des européens selon la commission
il ne parvient pas encore à convaincre
la totalité des états membres les pays
du sud dépendant du tourisme comme la
grèce se sont montrés parmi les premiers
favorables à sa mise
place mais d'autres se montrent plus
réticents parmi les sujets d'inquiétude
la protection des données des
utilisateurs ou encore l'aspect
discriminatoire du certificat valable
uniquement pour les quatre vaccins
autorisés par l' agence européenne des
médicaments il exclurait ainsi les
citoyens de pays comme la hongrie la
slovaquie ou la pologne qui ont reçu des
doses de sinopharm le sérum chinois ou
de spoutnik v le vaccin russe qui n'a
toujours pas été autorisé au niveau
européen
l'agencé européenne des médicaments qui
procède à l'enregistrement de tous les
médicaments retarde l'enregistrement de
scouts nick v je ne peux pas blâmer les
experts et spécialistes de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
mais nous savons avec certitude que ce
retard est dû à des signaux que leur
donne des personnes haut placées de
l'union européenne
quoi qu'il en soit les états membres
restent souverains dans la gestion de
leurs frontières intérieures
ils pourront donc définir d'autres
contours et usages à ce document la
commission elle espère aboutir à un
accord avant la saison touristique
estivale d'ici fin juin
si cette preuve de vaccination
standardisés réussissait à voir le jour
bruxelles devra encore toutefois se
confronter à une autre problématique
celle d'éviter les fraudes et le
développement d'un marché noir
à l'échelle européenne et pour en parler
nous sommes avec alexandra henrion côte
généticienne fondatrice de l'institut de
recherche simplissime à l'ancienne
directrice de recherche de l'inserm
bonsoir madame merci le travail
direct sur rt france on vient de le
constater l union européenne qui peine
manifestement à finaliser le certificat
sanitaire plutôt attendu pour faciliter
les voyages et notamment l'activité
touristique entre les pays de l'union
est ce que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut regretter que ce soit aussi
compliqué c'est urgent de le mettre en
place selon vous au
alors moi je vois pas vraiment l'urgence
au contraire je vais je vais simplement
de baser sur sur les experts de charge l
oms qui ont planché sur le sujet en
avril dernier la et qui est recommandé
de ne pas exiger de pazak sinal et les
raisons invoquées
c'était parce que l'épreuve était pour
eux limités dans la performance des
vaccins sur la balle à base de la
transmission donc ne serait ce que sur
la base de ces experts on a quand même
une très bonne raison de penser que ce
n'est pas une bonne idée qu'il ne faut
pas activer les choses dans une course
effrénée qui est à mon avis éminemment
dangereuse et pour à mon avis au moins
trois raisons d'une part parce que c'est
parfaitement anti démocratique
d'autre part parce qu'effectivement ça
représente un danger qui à mon avis
complètement sous-estimé sur la paix
sociale
et puis sur la santé des individus
et enfin parce que je pense que c'est
une dérive éthique qui est tout à fait
sans précédent dans ce cas qu'est ce que
vous préconisez une fermeture des
frontières entre les états membres qui
on le sait est est impossible dans
l'espace schengen ou alors quoi des
tests pcr davantage pour bien qu'une
passerelle est en fait je vais plutôt me
caler sur l'actualité
et éviter de décider de mesures qui ne
soit pas lié à la réalité de ce que nous
vivons
si j'en crois le dernier bulletin de
sentinelle de français on est à moins de
0 6% je crois des cas symptomatiques de
kobe de 19
donc je ne sais pas si avec dé tels
chiffres on est en droit d'exiger des
mesures aussi drastiques de tous côtés
je crois que on a perdu la raison dans
cette crise cela fait des mois que cela
dure et je pense qu'il est urgent de
revenir à quelque chose de 2,2 fondé de
biens bâtis et ces tests pcr que vous
mentionnez on le sait sont l'objet de
beaucoup de critiques
encore une fois notamment de l'om est
donc 1 me selon vous plus de paix certes
de vaccinations nécessaires pour passer
d'un pays à l'autre
c'est ce que vous préconisez auriez sans
danger justement de circulation et de
réguler résurgence du virus selon vont
alors je crois que dans l'état actuel de
la dynamique épidémique
ce que je propose là n'a rien de
révolutionnaire
je ne l'aurais pas forcément dit à
d'autres moments de l'épidémie mais ce
que ce que nous discutons là me semble
hautement réaliste
avec avec quand même des des précautions
qui sont toujours les mêmes mais qui
n'ont pas été qui ont été très
insuffisamment rappelé je veux parler de
l'hygiène des mains et qui a été mal
comprise
je veux parler de d'expliciter mieux les
façons de transmettre le virus
la même façon je crois qu'on on n'a pas
bien expliqué je veux parler de
l'immunité et de la force que représente
notre immunité naturelle et tout cela
n'a pas du tout été traités j'ai été
quand même une des premières a alerté
par des vidéos sur la symptomatologie
ducobu 19 donc s'il ya vraiment
quelqu'un qui ne nie pas ni les
symptômes que vides ni l'importance de
communiquer sur cette maladie c'est bien
moi comment vous expliquer justement ce
ton traitement comme vous dites de ce
que vous venez d'évoquer je l'expliqué
très simplement et hélas un très
prosaïquement l'autorisation de
transitoire conditionnel que nous avons
actuellement pour avoir accès à ces
vaccins avant même que les essais
cliniques soient terminés et avant même
d'ailleurs qu'un certain nombre de
processus de réguler a regular sion soit
atteint et bien te tiens au fait qu' il
soit disant il n'existe pas de
traitement
donc dès lors que quelqu'un apporte une
preuve qu'il existe des traitements vous
avez vu qu'un tout à coup une inde
aching internationale en disant non non
non ça ne marche pas c'est pas du tout
efficace vous pensez par exemple années
de roxy chloroquine et toutes les
polémiques qui ont suivi je alors chacun
pense à son clocher
moi j'étais plutôt une fan des deux
l'azithromycine pour avoir vu ses
bienfaits dans des dents des maladies
lourdes comme comme la mucoviscidose qui
a un dimension à la fois virales
bactériennes et virales
donc oui je trouvais que c'était plus
intéressant de par exemple assez lucide
mais enfin bon franchement depuis il ya
eu l'hiver mais tin ya eu oui lyderic
cyclos qui n'y a eu il ya eu quand même
beaucoup de traitements le n acétyl
système qui ont été proposées et qui à
chaque fois on montre des études qui
sont une accumulation d'études qui sont
quand même très impressionnante
pardonnez moi madame et on nous a dit
sur ce plateau ailleurs des experts
scientifiques également un nous ont dit
mais ce n'était pas un oui vous n'avez
pas inviter beaucoup de scientifiques
je crois que vous avez invité beaucoup
de médecins qui ont une capacité
scientifique évidente mais très peu très
peu scientifique mais pas que vous
heurtez l'ensemble des plateaux et
c'était une grosse différence parce
qu'en fait la différence avec un
scientifique un scientifique qui mangent
du papier la publication matin midi et
soir
de qui la voient la ccc son beach et de
manger de la publication a eu
quelques-uns d'ailleurs inquiets qu'ils
défendent est justement ici même ces
traitements puisque on a l'habitude de
donner justement des voix dissonantes
donc on en a eu si si je vous assure
mais c'est vrai qu'on en a entendu
d'autres nous dire bah écoutez tout le
monde sait évidemment que ces
traitements ne sont pas efficaces du
tout enfin c'était une fin de non
recevoir lors de débats justement qui a
opposé ces deux opinions qu'est ce que
vous répondez médecins qui sont
pardonnez moi ils sont d'autant moins
efficaces qu'ils n'ont pas été donné et
que à la place on a dit de lits pran
paracétamol donc effectivement dès lors
qu'ils ne sont pas autorisés données
d'une façon générale les biens
effectivement on a l'impression qu'ils
sont inefficaces si vous aussi vous
écouter tous les témoignages de tous et
généraliste qui ont traité leurs
patients et qui ne sont pas rester
simplement avec la leur donner du pain
c'est un vol il semblerait que la vérité
serait tout autre effectivement je vous
le confirme pour connaître effectivement
certains médecins qui ont prescrit
l'azithromycine al'inverse à des entités
mini que si elle différente
al'inverse l'union européenne 1 qui
peinent à se mettre d'accord dans dans
sein de ses frontières se prépare à
ouvrir grand ses portes aux visiteurs
ces étrangers condition qu'ils aient
reçu là encore le vaccin votre réaction
c'est bien on s'arrange contre le
tourisme voilà quand il s'agit de faire
venir les touristes et quand même une
bonne chose selon vous si jamais on ne
le conditionne pas cette histoire de pas
5 et une vraiment très très dangereux et
je crois que les gens ne mesurent pas le
danger a sorti à ce passé j'aimerais
peut-être prendre une minute pour vous
l'expliquer en vous donnant des exemples
quand j'ai dit que c'est le danger
c'était la destruction de toute forme de
paix sociale et bien des exemples du
peuple israélien
c'est que par exemple si vous nous avons
envie de faire la fête quand vous voyez
vos amis qui restent dehors et qu'ils ne
peuvent pas rentrer et ce que vous
croyez vraiment vous avez toujours envie
de faire la fête
petit exemple vécu papa et maman vont
avec leurs trois enfants
le restaurant est là bien évidemment les
enfants ne sont pas vaccinés
donc ils sont parqués ils sont parqués
au delà d'une démarcation et donc ne
déjeunent pas on ne dîne pas avec leurs
parents dans les restaurants ces salles
exemple israélien qu'on nous dit être
tellement sympathique où ses invités à
débattre médias qui ne peuvent pas y
aller parce qu'ils n'ont pas lent
pastille verte ou cette femme qui n'a
pas pu aller voir son mari dans une
maison de retraite parce que elles
n'étaient pas vaccinés donc elle ne peut
plus accéder à la maison de retraite
est ce que vous vous rendez compte de ce
que je suis en train de vous raconter ça
c'est ça la réalité du pass vaccinale ça
n'est pas
prends l'avion et le tourisme est résolu
et tout va bien on a vu ce sont ces cas
de l'australien double vaccinés qui se
retrouvaient en quarantaine dans le pays
visité
parce que il était positif à la pcr donc
vous voyez il ya quand même il ya le
narratif qui est qui est effrayant parce
que quand même il
il fait des petits début insignifiant et
en fait c'est c'est par ce début
insignifiant on peut renverser
véritablement toutes nos principes
démocratiques et toute notre capacité de
vivre ensemble ne serait-ce que non et
famille donc ça c'est une aspects le
deuxième aspect que j'aimerais dire
c'est au tour de la santé finalement
cette idée de passants à mon avis met en
danger la santé des individus
et ça personne n'en pas non plus en quoi
si on écoute simplement ce que monsieur
vers ans explique l'autre jour au
conseil d'état il nous a quand même dit
que les personnes vaccinées étaient
aussi celles qui étaient les plus
exposées aux formes graves dues au décès
en cas d'inefficacité initiale du vaccin
ou de réinfection post vaccinales il a
aussi parlé de deux du cas de la
virulence d'invariants donc il nous a
bien expliqué que le vaccin n'empêche
pas de transmettre le virus aux tiers et
donc ceux qui auront à passes vont se
croire nantis protéger quand ils ne le
sont pas ils ne vont ils sont donc dans
une certaine forme infantiliser c'est
une infantilisation dangereuse qui peut
les mettre en danger parce qu'ils vont
baisser leur garde et pour être exact
est fidèle à ce que les grands patrons
de modern iphise heures nous annonce
c'est que nous avons la quasi assurance
que plutôt que impasse sanitaire nous
aurons bien un abonnement vaccinale
chronique qui a priori sera tous les six
mois
donc ce n'est pas un passe vaccinale
dont on parle pas un pass sanitaire
c'est bien parce que le côté sanitaire
on a vu que c'était tout à fait
critiquable c'est un abonnement
vaccinale chronique merci en tout cas
alexandra henrion caudin généticienne
fondatrice de l'institut de recherche
simplissime ans et ancienne directrice
de recherche de l'inserm d'avoir été
avec nous nous avons exposé votre point
de vue ce soir sur rtl france en côte
d'ivoire à présent guillaume soro il son
clan à nouveau face à la justice
l'ancien premier ministre et candidat à
l'élection présidentielle ainsi qu'une
vingtaine de ses proches vont être jugés
pour tentative présumée de complot
contre le gouvernement ouattara la fin
de l'année 2019 les détails et en images
après avoir été condamné en avril 2020 à
20 ans de prison pour blanchiment et
recel de détournements de deniers
publics
guillaume soro est cette fois poursuivi
pour complot et atteintes contre
l'autorité de l'état en exil en europe
depuis sa tentative de retour avortée à
abidjan le 23 décembre 2019
l'ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale ivoirienne devrait comme une
partie de ses dix neuf coprévenus être
jugé par contumace devant le tribunal
criminel d'abidjan c'est par exemple le
cas d'une des avocates de guillaume soro
l'ancien ministre un fiat à bamba lamine
également en exil
d'autres sont en détention provisoire
comme l'ancien ministre et député alain
lobognon
tous encourent la prison à vie les faits
remontent au 23 décembre 2019 au siège
du gps le mouvement politique de soro la
police arrête une quinzaine de personnes
parmi lesquelles alain lobognon
soro qui n'a pas été appréhendé et avec
certains de ses proches suspecté de
fomenter un complot contre le pouvoir
pièce maîtresse de l'accusation un
enregistrement audio de soro évoquant
des projets d'insurrection ou encore de
projets de campagne de discrédit des
autorités à cela s'ajoute selon le
procureur des armes saisies lors de
l'enquêté le camp sort on reconnaît
l'existence de l'enregistrement mais le
qualifie d'un complet est tronquée il
s'agirait selon les proches de l'ancien
premier ministre d'une manipulation
destinée à le piéger
le collectif d'avocats qui défend
guillaume soro a fait savoir par un
courrier adressé au président et aux
juges du tribunal qui ne prêteraient pas
leur concours à ce qu'il qualifie de
simulacre de procès un règlement de
compte politique visant à écarter
monsieur guillaume soro et les cadres de
son mouvement des affaires politiques du
pays ont-ils précisé
lors de son précédent procès en 2020 la
condamnation de guillaume soro avait
conduit à la privation de ses droits
civiques
alors qu'il était candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et pour en parler nous
sommes avec vous si et bamba avocat de
guillaume soro bonsoir à tous niveaux
bas merci d'être avec nous vous avez
déclaré hier vivre un simulacre de
procès un règlement de compte politique
visant à écarter
guillaume soro pourquoi de tels mots ben
parce que c'est ce que c'est
malheureusement c'est un simulacre de
procès et donc nous avons décidé de ne
pas y colle pas pourquoi la tenue de
cette audience c'est même une insulte
aux deux décisions qui ont été rendus
par la cour africaine des droits de
l'homme est là qu une décision très
claire
l'année dernière 2020 le 22 avril 2020
exactement pour dire qu'il fallait gérer
la procédure aussi concerne monsieur
guillaume kigbafori soro et libéré tous
ses proches
ensuite le 15 dès septembre 2001 elle a
repris mme de notre décision lorsqu'il
s'est vu écarté par
la commission électorale indépendante et
ne pas être déclaré comme candidat la
cour africaine s'était prononcée de
nouveau elle avait dit qu'il fallait
qu'il soit candidat et que ses droits
politiques soient respectés donc rien
que pour le respect de cette décision
l'audience d'aujourd'hui n'auraient
jamais dû se tenir et pour nous c'est
une mascarade alors ce que quand on
respecte droit quand on a un minimum de
respect de la primauté du droit parce
que la décision de la cour africaine
sont revêtus du droit de la primauté du
droit international s'est reconnu dans
toutes les constitutions des pays y
compris la côte d'ivoire la côte
d'ivoire donc aurait dû en respectant
cette décision considérant que cette
décision avec une force supérieure à
celle des décisions internes est donc le
magistrat aurait dû donc gelé toute la
procédure et attendre que les juges
africains donc de cette cour africaine
des droits de l'homme et des peuples se
prononce sur la procédure avant d'aller
plus loin dans le dossier
alors on le rappelle à mme affoussy
bamba vous vous faites partie justement
des accusés comment justement vous
expliquez que là qu'on ne l'ait pas fait
en fait c'est justement si j'avais été
inculpé dès le départ il est évident que
mon nom aurait été dans ceux de toutes
les personnes qu'il entend on dans la
requête a été déposée devant la cour
africaine des droits de l'homme
mais je n'étais pas inculpé dans le
dossier moi même et certains de mes
compagnons qui se retrouvent aussi être
en exil comme le président du cps
monsieur guillaume kigbafori soro
il s'agit donc de touré moussa ici un
cas fofana le député monsieur bel souk
tous n'avons pas été cité dans la
procédure
la vente a été cité dans le réquisitoire
introductif d'instance
donc nous n'avons pas été que nous
n'avons pas été entendus
tout le long de la procédure et
subitement à la fin on apprend donc que
nous serons aussi donc renvoyé comme
tous les autres devant le juge
le criminel s'est même pas devant le
tribunal correctionnel devant le juge
criminel pour être jugé et cela au
mépris encore une fois de plus du code
de procédure pénal ivoirien à l'article
208 209 qui dit qu'une personne doit
être inculpé formellement par rapport
aux réquisitoires donc introductif du
procureur est ensuite donc après devant
les juridictions donc devant le tribunal
correctionnel où le tribunal criminel
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans vous
imaginez il ya tellement de je dirais de
faussetés dans ce dossier il ya
tellement de grossièretés on se pose la
question de savoir comment des
magistrats qui ont fait un minimum de
d'études de droit qui sont des
techniciens de droit on tue se prêtait
donc à ce jeu vous êtes donc à distance
comment comptez vous organiser votre
défense et celle de guillaume soro à
distance
non nous avons collectif d'avocats et ce
collectif donc que je coordonne le
collectif d'avocats des avocats qui sont
barreau de côte d'ivoire et au barreau
de paris
un jeu que je coordonne ce collectif et
nous avions des avocats qui étaient
présents à cette audience parce que bon
il ya monsieur guillaume kigbafori soro
il ya moi même et les autres mais
également ceux qui sont à abidjan tout à
l'heure dans votre film vous avez parlé
de michel lobognon monsieur souleymane
camara t
les freins du président soro donc si
monsoreau et tous ceux là ont besoin
aussi d'être assisté par les avocats
dont nous avons les avocats qui
assistent à l'audience mais ce qu'il est
important de dire je crois que nous
l'avons répété tout le long de la
procédure
depuis l'année dernière nous avons dit
qu'il s'agissait d'une mascarade que
c'était vraiment un acharnement
judiciaire contre une personne et je
crois que là aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'en rendent même celui qui ne connaît
pas le droit c'est à dire n'importe quel
quidam peut voir aujourd'hui que c'est
c'est du n'importe quoi je vous assure
que l'audience d'aujourd'hui
- la limite je dirais que j'ai de la
peine pour ces magistrats comme on peut
se prêter à une telle parodie et je
crois même que le mot parodie est trop
faible pour exprimer exactement ce qui
s'est passé nous avons donc le président
monsieur alassane ouattara qui a dit
clairement qu'il n'allait jamais
appliqué la décision de la cour
africaine qui l'a dit et nous avons une
vidéo qui le recul indique qu'ils ont
très clairement
deuxièmement il a dit que guillaume
kigbafori soro prendrait la perpétuité
il a dit au cours d'une interview qui
est donc de notoriété publique
un docu réalité du service à ouattara
saint luc et le procureur
donc monsieur adou richard les personnes
mariées
ces marionnettes c'est lui qui est le
magistrat instructeur donc c'est lui qui
instruit le dossier
le doyen des juges d'instruction
monsieur victor ousmane coulibaly en
réalité n'est qu'un chemin entre ses
mains et enfin de salut qui juge
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
décision est déjà arrêtée elle a été
déjà rédigé par me sa récente dramane
ouattara et elle ne saurait donc énoncé
par les magistrats
c'est tout donc voilà ambroise montre
avant tout c'est lui qui poursuit on il
instruit il juge donc vous botella de
cergy indépendant solde de la justice au
coeur de ce clairement c'est que
l'annoncé clairement ça au coeur de ce
dossier d'accusation
un enregistrement audio celui de
guillaume soro on l'entend parler d'un
projet d'insurrection et qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire sur cet
enregistrement
mais sur le registre mais je pourrais al
ahly vous poser la question en tant que
journaliste si vous pensez à un radier
bethel personne je ne les aime pas je
vais la tuer est ce que vous avez commis
un crime en ont acheté un combiné non je
vous pose la question ça veut donc dire
quoi ça veut donc dire ce qu'on entend
dans une audio et le passage à l'acte ça
fait deux donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que le fait de le dire ne suffit
pas c'est pour ça que le droit pénal il
faut la constitution de trois éléments
qui sont très importants est l'élément
légal est l'élément intentionnel est en
fait un élément matériel qui matérialise
de passage à l'acte mais il ya un
élément matériel
nous n'avons aucun élément matériel en
outils voilà il ya un complot contre aux
gens tout aussi bas qu est ce que vous
craignez le plus on craignait une
extradition pour vous cette affaire va
aller là où on me dit mais je viens de
vous le démontrer a même pas
d'extradition possible parce que
justement j'allais signer par là c'est
que la décision des magistrats
il voit rien cette décision et ne soit
appliquée en côte d'ivoire cei décision
ivoiro ivoirienne qui tournera en côte
d'ivoire elle ne sera jamais appliqué
dans aucun pays qui se respecte on ya un
minimum de respect pour le droit
je goûte je finirai peut-être par là
quand vous voyez les décisions parfois
des magistrats le savaient qu'ils
peuvent prendre les décisions en tenant
un peu le coup droit et vous vous dites
bon c'est vrai que
décision elle tend le cou au droit mais
c'est tellement bien rédigé tellement
bien argumenté qu'à la limite vous êtes
je dirais admiratif de cette décision
mais là il s'agit d'une grossière paix
tellement grave et sa main la côte
d'ivoire définitivement au rang d'état
voyou soit la salle
cette décision ne sera plus que par les
magistrats ivoiriens elle ne sera
appliquée pas aucun aucune autre
juridiction d'aucun pays au monde que je
vous dis mais pourquoi fossiles man-made
avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain par compression l'actualité ce
sera dans quelques minutes
[Musique]